foreign
[Music]
employee
foreign
[Music]
can somebody get up there and say
the house will come to water the chair
recognizes the member from Auburn
representative Osborne removes the house
adjourned from the session of February
23 2023.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye those opposed nay the
eyes have it the house will attend to a
Prayer by house chaplain Reverend Bob
Stewart pastor of Saint Paul's United
o god of love
you call each of us by name
not by a number
or by a party affiliation
you call us by name
you call us to represent those that have
elected us to represent them to the best
of our abilities
for this we are ever so grateful
for your leading and guiding hand
o God of Peace
I pray that you would Grant a faith and
understanding in the work that will come
before this body today
may you guide your people gathered here
today with a spirit of gentleness and
kindness when dealing with each other
o God of integrity
let us do nothing for personal gain or
reputation
but everything to fulfill the mission
that you have set before us for this
oh god of Grace
I pray for governor sununu
I pray for speaker Packard
I pray for every leader of this house
and I pray for every representative
of this house
each member that you have called by name
I pray for their health
happiness
and safety
I pray that as they work together today
that their work is fruitful
o God of Light
illuminate the path we are to follow
and let us be mindful that in all that
we do
it is to your glory that we do our work
it is in your name Creator God of the
universe that we pray
amen
the chair recognizes the member from
Temple representative Diane Kelly who
Jr recognizes Kelly ordell daughter of
Representative Diane Kelly who will now
oh say can you see
by the dawn's early
light
what's so proud ly we
held at the
twilight's last gleaming whose broad
stripes and bright
stars through the
perilous five
8 or the rest
[Music]
we watched were so
gallantly streaming
and the rockets
[Music]
it gave proof through the night that our
flag was still there
away
or the land
fan
[Applause]
thank you
the house will attend to requests for
leaves of absence
Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Bartlett goalie hatch
lewicki Mason massmilla Montiel Ellen
Reed and teles the day important
business Buco Arnold Davis William Dolan
hacken Phillips Heath Lloyd magior
Malloy McGee Merchant Sinclair
these leaves of absence shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
the house will attend to the
introduction of guests Mr Steely in
order
Mr Speaker please welcome clay Lasher
Summers guest of representative Harvey
Alana taylorski daughter of
Representative tulersky Gene Taylor
spouse of Representative Chris Schultz
third fourth and fifth grade students
from Shaker Road School in Concord
guests of Representative Hicks and
floydian Kelly and Terry Davis
grandmother of the singer and guest of
Representative Diane Kelly they're with
us in the gallery today
yeah
the house will attend away communication
Mr Speaker in a letter dated March 8
2023 Mr Paul Smith Clerk of the house
dear Paul please be advised that the
following representative elect was sworn
into office by the governor and
executive Council on this day Stratford
County District 8 Chuck grassy of
Rochester sincerely David scandler
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will now attend to revenue
estimates
H.R 17 which is located in your seat
Pockets then Sanborn moves Auto pass
representative Sanborn Olney are
thank you Mr Speaker first I'd like to
thank all the members of the House Ways
and Means Committee for their amazing
efforts and contributions in the revenue
estimating process every single person
on the committee did an excellent job
working together we heard from many
agencies and outside experts over
several months in order to get the best
possible understanding of our
unrestricted Revenue sources and the
economy at large as many of you would
probably agree there is much uncertainty
about what the short-term and
medium-term future looks like
we relied heavily on state agencies to
provide detailed information on their
operations and revenue and revenue
expectations for the remainder of this
fiscal year as well as the next two
years we looked at all of these Revenue
sources from the very small to the very
large
we have seen record growth rates above
plan or official estimates in some of
these areas in the 17 to 33 percent
range this year this has been quite
surprising and of course cannot be
expected to continue forever
like many of you we are concerned about
a recession or a downturn in the economy
overall and New Hampshire is no
exception all of us are heavily impacted
by inflation and Rising interest rates
and this situation is expected to
continue
so how much of a downturn will we see in
New Hampshire when will it occur and how
long will it last these are the
questions we wrestled with every day in
the committee
in the end we built these Revenue
estimates from the bottom up
Brick by Brick to provide the numbers
before you today and just so you know
these are in your seat Pockets Color of
Money
overall we came in slightly below the
governor's estimates he was slightly
more optimistic than us on business
taxes as we expect these revenues to
actually go down in 2024 approximately
2.5 percent and then Grow Again one
percent in 2025.
however our committee was slightly more
optimistic than the governor on meals
and rooms taxes we actually believe they
will grow 1.5 percent in 2024 and then
2.5 percent in 2025.
the toughest Revenue estimate for us was
the real estate transfer tax
we started to see some warning signs
here in New Hampshire in January and
February we believe the volume and
prices of home sales will decrease about
5 in 2024 and then remain flat or stable
in 2025.
in summary these numbers before you are
thoughtful reasonable and cautious
estimates we hope that you will support
the unanimous bipartisan efforts of this
committee and now I'll turn it over to
representative Army for her expert
wisdom
thank you I'm very glad we've been able
to reach agreement on our Revenue
estimates because this year is the most
challenging that I have seen since the
Great Recession
we cannot know the effect of several
structural changes made in the
all-important business taxes in recent
years until at least 2024.
but there is reason to worry about the
single sales factor and the credit carry
forward changes the first of which on
was brought forward by on the Senate and
the second of which was brought forward
by us on
economists are reconsidering their
predictions of a recession or a simple
Slowdown
weekly daily
it is just about impossible to do
anything except a crystal ball
you need to understand that the
governor's Revenue estimates had to be
set in cement in December so we are
operating with about 10 weeks more
information than he had
and I believe that at least on some of
these uh his uh his man who came to us
has agreed that
he was also lower
on I built I think that we agreed with
the February agency estimates 11 times
including the highway and fishing game
funds and with the median of the
Department of Revenue administration's
estimate Range four times and you've
just heard about I believe
I I heard that you say talk about the
real estate transfer tax
the interest in dividends tax the meals
and rooms tax and the business taxes
where we were 45 million below
the Department's median for the two
years about two percent
this is our hardest text to negotiate
because of what all the economists are
doing
and um
because each of us has different
experiences of
where we may be in the recession issue
we found ourselves in the cells in the
end 1.2 percent only below the agency's
numbers and 77 million dollars short of
them though a hundred million dollars
short of the December estimate that the
governor did
thank you if there are any questions
the question is on the motion of ought
to pass are you ready for the question
all those who care to say hi
you guys have it the motion is adopted
representative Sandberg moves that house
the question is on the motion delay HR
17 on the table are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
hey you guys have it and emotion is
adopted
I also now attend to the consent
calendar
Mr Speaker from the committee on
Municipal and County government House
Bill 294 removed by representative Simon
popovichi Mueller yokela J Heinz Gerhard
Tom Manion wheeler Granger and Santa
nastasso
are there any other bills to be removed
from the consent calendar
representative Wiseman moves at the
consent calendar with the relevant
amendments as printed in today's health
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have been the
consent calendar is adopted the house
majority committee on criminal justice
of Public Safety to which it was
referred House Bill 31 FN Act repealing
of prohibition on the possession or sale
of black chaps
slingshots and metallic Knuckles have
been considered the same report the same
with the recommendation of Bill on a
pass Senator Terry Roy from the majority
of the committee
minority in the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is in
expedient to legislate Senator David
moves for the minority or the committee
which I recognizes representative Muse
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker and good morning
colleagues
there are many things that we need in
New Hampshire we need lower energy
prices we need housing and we need
cheaper child care
but something that we don't need is a
bill that makes our streets our
gathering places and our schools any
less safe than they already are and
that's exactly what HB 31 would do
it would end our state's current
prohibition on carrying or possessing
with the intent to sell
blackjacks metallic Knuckles better
known as brass knuckles
and an old-time dealer of Mayhem known
as a slung shot
so if you're like me you might be
thinking that the sponsors of the bill
might have misspelled slingshot that's
actually not the case a slingshot is
actually a different animal
a slingshot doesn't shoot a projectile
what it what it is is basically a heavy
metal or stone weight that's attached to
a short rope or strap that's used in the
same potentially deadly way is a
blackjack so think of it as something
you twirl around and you can hit
somebody with
currently carrying or possessing these
weapons with the intent to sell them is
a misdemeanor in New Hampshire and
that's for very good reason
a quick online search reveals case after
case in state after state where these
weapons have been used to horrible
effect in assaults
in addition to inflicting concussions
and potential brain damage these weapons
can fracture skulls and break bones
lacerations from brass knuckle attacks
can leave wounds that require dozens of
stitches and plastic surgery to fix
that's if they can be fixed at all
something that I kept looking for as I
as I searched for information that would
be helpful would be even one story or
article that might actually show a case
or example of how these weapons are
actually used in self-defense to stop an
attacker
but while you it can occasionally find a
good gun a good guy with a gun story
there don't seem to be any good guy with
brass knuckle stories
please join me in pushing the red button
to defeat the ought to pass motion so
another motion can be made and Mr
Speaker I request a division vote thank
you
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this
bill is not about slung shots although I
thank the representative because I had
no idea what that was either
um or brass knuckles or any of these
things frankly do you know what else
causes horrible injury a wrench a
baseball bat a piece of pipe none of
those things are illegal
these are specifically targeted because
they're archaic when this was written
they were popular
if I challenge anyone in the room now Mr
Speaker to go on amazon.com you can
order a set of brass knuckles they call
them a paperweight it's not like these
things haven't been around they've been
around
there's no rash of assaults with with
these or would there be one because as I
said people can already have baseball
bats screwdrivers you name it
frankly this is about the Second
Amendment and so far as the courts ruled
that anything that can be handheld is a
personal weapon for example tasers we
all see tasers they sell them at Walmart
it's an electric weapon
the Supreme Court said you can have
those so why are we targeting these
antiques to say that you can't have them
they're available for self-defense
someone smaller than someone else may
find that helpful to use to protect
themselves there's a lot of scenarios
where someone could use something like
this small handy in their pocket
probably not a slung shot though that
sounds kind of complicated but as I said
this is a second amendment issue it's
not really about the name of the weapons
in here it's the fact that whether or
not our citizens have the right to
defend themselves with any available
weapon that they can have in their hand
representative Senator natasto has
requested a roll call and that is
sufficiently seconded members take your
seats
[Music]
foreign
the chair recognizes representative Muse
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that unlike a wrench The Wider
circulation of weapons with a long and
storied history of being used in violent
criminal assaults won't make our cities
our streets our schools or our gathering
places any safer
and if I know the vast majority of
people who put us here would be appalled
if this bill passes then would I pass
the red button so another motion may be
made
chair recognizing representative Manion
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that prohibiting The Possession or
sale of antiquated arms such as
Blackjack slung shots or metallic
Knuckles violates the Second Amendment
and is unconstitutional and if I know
that they are still useful for
self-defense and should not be banned
while more lethal weapons are not banned
and if I know that under New Hampshire
law any item that could cause serious
bodily injury or death can be considered
a deadly weapon and finally Mr Speaker
if I know that very few people even know
what a slung shot is but I now press the
members make sure you've turned your
your buttons on
so you can vote
the motion before us is a majority
committed report of autopass and House
Bill 31 is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
foreign
[Music]
representative representative Corinthian
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to the state
196 voting yay 176 14 a committee report
facility
majority of the committee on criminal
justice of Public Safety to which was
referred House Bill 32 FN act relative
to possession a discharge of a firearm
in a safe school zone consider the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that as inexpected
to legislate instead of Jennifer Rhodes
the minority of the committee have been
considered the same and be an unable to
agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation to fill out a pass St
Lawrence C league for the minority of
the committee chair recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker it was a month ago today that
the criminal justice committee met in
this chamber it took up HP 32 and
several other builds
it is the prime sponsor of this bill I
was the first one to speak that day
and that was somewhat bittersweet
because my speaking pot was finished but
sitting down and hearing other people
get up and speak against the bill
in expressing their opinions was
somewhat disappointing to me
the late U.S senator Senator Daniel
Patrick Moynihan once said
everybody is entitled to their opinions
but everybody is not entitled to their
facts
so when I was thinking about speaking to
all of you today I thought what I would
do
was go back to that
hearing a month ago
and try to address some of the things I
heard in the testimony from those who
were opposed to this legislation
one woman from Manchester
told the committee that she had she
lived in Manchester and she had two
daughters that she brought to school
and she was concerned with the bill
because under this bill she would not be
able to carry her gun with her have her
gun with her when dropping them off
and I had a very nice email from a
member of the House who addressed that
same issue he brought his children to
school every morning he carried a gun
and um
and as I said to him in my email in
response under this bill it clearly says
that if you're not going onto the school
grounds
you're not doing anything wrong if you
come onto the school grounds and you
want to go into the school then you've
got to make sure your firearm is secured
in the vehicle
but for people dropping children off
that is not a problem the same with one
man that said now I can't drive by my
school if I'm on because I'm in within a
thousand feet of the school
as the legislation says this bill
pertains to those on the school grounds
not carrying a firearm with them
the bill says that if you come onto the
school grounds in your arm then you've
got to secure your gun in your vehicle
like you normally would anyway before
going into the school
now I've been a licensed Tanner in New
Hampshire now for over 50 years
actually 10 years over 50 years
God I'm getting old but um
so I'm not anti-gun and I own guns long
guns and handguns
and there's a provision in this build I
know a lot of people myself when I was
in school used to go deer hunting after
school
there's a provision if a student wants
to go hunting you just keep your shotgun
if you're going or a rifle just locked
up in the rack of the vehicle keep it
secure in the vehicle if you're crossing
school property to get to a cornfield to
go bird hunting you just unload the
shotgun and cross the property you're
fine
uh one person said and I think it was at
the hearing well if your home is next to
the school
now you're within a thousand feet of
school you can't own a gun
no part two of the bill if you read it
says this bill does not pertain to
private property
of course you can reach out to your
kitchen window and touch the school you
can still own it
own a gun if it's just when you're on
school property
um
I'm trying to think of some of the other
things one person I understand said if
I'm walking into my children to school
and I'm assaulted I can't use my weapon
to defend my children and myself
again
if you're on a public way the bill says
as long as you shouldn't on a school
property and you have a legal right to
have a firearm you have a legal right to
defend yourself
we got a lot of bills today and I'm
going to stop here but you know
I didn't submit this bill because I'm
anti-gun or Auntie Hunter because I am
one
I submitted this bill really for two
reasons
Sarah and Alex those are my
grandchildren and I'm thinking about
your grandchildren your kids there are
certain places in New Hampshire we just
don't allow Firearms airports jails
prisons courtrooms and other places we
don't need them on school grounds and
I'd ask you to please to support this
Bill thank you Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker we just heard a lot of facts
I would like to address some of those
facts
the fact is it is murder
if you take a weapon into a school
and your intention is to kill somebody
and you do it
this bill will not make it
former Mr Speaker mentioned that if you
want to go hunting you can still do that
however if you read the bill it clearly
states that if you need to access a
hunting trail that you have to access
by means of a school ground you have to
have permission
from somebody at the school in order to
do that
he mentioned that this does not affect
you if you have private property with
that's within a thousand feet of a
school zone
okay well it may not affect you if you
live within a thousand feet
but what about if you are walking your
child to school
what happens when you get within a
thousand feet are you supposed to put
your firearm in somebody's mailbox
you're supposed to just lay it down mean
he mentioned if you're picking your
child up from school okay well if you
read the bill
you have to have your gun unloaded or it
has to be locked I can stand here and
give you examples of family members that
I have had unfortunately maybe many of
you have had that did not have the
opportunity to call and ask for help
they didn't have the opportunity to call
for a police officer
I have a family member that is dead
today because he didn't have the ability
to call and ask for help
the fact of the matter is if you have
if you're carrying your gun on a school
ground you've had to go to your local
police department you had to go get a
concealed carry permit which means you
had to fill out
a form you had to go through a
background check in order to be able to
legally have that
no time under any circumstances should a
person lose their ability to protect
themselves or their loved ones
regardless of the grounds they're on
regardless of the county that they're in
period Please support the committee
representative son and natasto has
requested a roll call and it is
sufficiently seconded members take your
seats
first
clear
ly
foreign
chair recognizes representative C league
my daughter was in kindergarten with Mrs
raspa that in addition to learning her
alphabet and how to count she also
learned how to hide in a closet in case
Bears attacked
and if I know that when my older
daughter as a senior in high school who
weighs less than 100 pounds and stands
under five feet tall has to walk into
every classroom
first looking for exits then looking for
hiding places then looking for
projectiles
and then looking for who in the
classroom she believes is more important
than she is so she knows whose body to
throw her own in front of
and if I know that in the first three
months of this year more than one
thousand children and teenagers have
been killed or wounded by gunfire
and if I believe that if we were to
oppose the itl
and allow for another motion that that
other motion would support the public
good would I now press the red button to
oppose the itl so another motion can be
made
sure I recognize representative Roy for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that most recently when there was
an incident out of school the people who
were supposed to help stood outside and
waited while people were slaughtered and
Mr Speaker if I know that having a
weapon with you would not make you have
to wait on someone else to save you and
finally Mr Speaker if I know that the
Second Amendment for Hicks the right to
protect ourselves and others
everywhere and Mr Speaker finally if I
know that if a school happened to have
10 acres a thousand feet from that could
put you almost in another state would I
push the green button thank you question
before is the majority committee report
of inexpension legislative in House Bill
32 this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
your opposed you'll press the red button
boarding stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
members president had an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
199 voting yay 174 voting a the
majority committee on criminal justice
and Public Safety to which was referred
House Bill 59 FN after acquiring a
background check prior to any commercial
fire on sale considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is in expedient to
legislate Senator Jonathan stone for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
Fallen Amendment and a recommendation to
Bill ought to pass with Amendment
percent of Ray Newman from Minority of
the committee chair recognizes Senator
Newman
House Bill 59 is a fairly simple bill
it's about background checks
it's about closing a loophole in the
background check system
for some types of guns so for some types
of guns that are procured online through
certain
um
Gun Show Gun Show loophole where the
people don't get a proper background
check
background checks are constitutional
they're common sense and they save lives
background checks are the foundation of
any comprehensive gun violence
the primary objective of a background
check is to keep Firearms out of the
background checks do not restrict or
regulate firearms
they regulate buyers
they prohibit they keep guns out of the
they only regulate and prevent firearm
sales to people or prohibited persons
and actually they do not have the right
to own a gun under the Second Amendment
Law requires background checks only for
sales completed by a licensed firearm
dealer
this situation effectively exempts
commercial transactions between private
parties
the bill seeks to close this loophole in
state and federal law
by requiring commercial transactions
taking place between private parties who
are not licensed firearm dealers
and who do not know each other
to include a background check obtained
one of the objections you will hear
about this bill is that as written
every time a unlicensed seller transfers
or sells or transfers of firearm they
have to get a background check
due to an unfortunate clerical error
a critical paragraph Was omitted from
the bill as submitted
that paragraph indicated that background
checks are not required if it can be
ascertained that neither party to the
transaction is a primitive person
however the omitted language is a is
actually in the analysis of the bill it
actually says that in the bill but that
so I'm asking you to please vote no to
defeat the itl
read the amendment
0387 printed in the calendar on page 33.
so the clerical error can be corrected
in an ought to pass with Amendment
motion can be made
thank you Mr Speaker and I asked for a
division vote
thank you Mr Speaker
this bill changed the definition of a
commercial sale
currently this bill is unnecessary
conflicting and duplicative
currently all federal firearms licensed
dealers are required to conduct a
background check on all firearms sales
and transfers
in the state of New Hampshire the
department of safety additionally
conducts all handgun in what's
classified as another sale
the all long guns Firearms purchases
that are conducted via the Federal
Bureau of Investigation Nix Center for
each entity provides a tracking number
regardless of the status
of the outcome
under current federal law
under the age of 21
anyone is automatically delayed and
additionally delayed for 10 days this
was part of bipartisan support that was
just implemented I believe it was around
one of the concerning parts of this bill
is establishing the following definition
of commercial sales being transfer
ownership of a firearm included but not
limited to the sale exchange or gift
another concerning part of this bill is
159 F3 successful completion of a
background check no firearms shall be
delivered to an individual pursuant to a
commercial sale until Nix has issued a
proceed response
it is not uncommon in the Firearms
business to not receive a proceed status
for weeks months on a very rare occasion
it should be judicially noted that
Firearms is transferred and the buyer is
found to be a prohibited person the batf
bureau called back on firearms and the
New Hampshire State Police are notified
by the dealer currently New Hampshire
law prohibits a sale transfer of a
firearm to a person who is not
personally known to the seller this
makes sales to strangers via online
advertisement
or at a gun show or via other venues
illegal a citizen of New Hampshire
should not be denied a natural and
constitutional right to protect
themselves because of government
inefficiency this bill was not asked for
by any New Hampshire law enforcement
agencies nor did any testify in favor of
it
the so-called
loophole all federal firearm dealers who
are at gun shows have the same
obligation to conduct a background check
on every buyer that is a fact
representative Senator Natasha was
requested a roll call and is
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of any speed the United
States and House Bill 59 this is a roll
call vote Jr recognizes representative
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know background checks are
constitutional common sense and they
save lives and are the foundation of any
comprehensive gun violence prevention
strategy
and if I know the bill seeks to close
the loophole in state and federal law
that allows unlicensed people who do not
know each other to complete a firearm
sale without a background check
and finally if I know that the bill as
introduced omits critical information
that describes when background checks
are not required
would I now press the red button so that
the itl can be defeated the clerical
Omission can be corrected and the bill
can be debated in its entirety thank you
Geo recognize representative Roy for a
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that it is current New Hampshire
law that it is illegal to sell a firearm
to someone you don't know and it is
current federal law that is a felony to
sell a firearm to someone who is a
prohibited person
and Mr Speaker if I know that the only
way to enforce this law would be to
create a gun registry so that they could
track every single gun that is traded
would I now vote Green in Sports
Committee position in itl this bill
motion before us the majority committee
report of inexpedia to legislate on
House Bill 59 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote
197 voting yay 175 voting 80 committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on criminal
justice Public Safety to which those
referred House Bill 78 an actor
repealing enact prohibiting the state
from enforcing any federal statute
regulation or presidential executive
order that restricts or regulates the
right of people to keep or bear arms
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpeding to legislative Senator
Jonathan stone for majority of committee
the minority having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the recommendation Bill
ought to pass Linda Harriet goth Wright
for the minority of the committee chair
recognizes the representative goth
Wright
the bill would reveal
that this bill would repeal a law
prohibiting New Hampshire counties towns
and schools from enforcing or even
cooperating with any federal law rule
regulation or executive order regarding
firearms and knives unless it is also in
state law
as mass shootings gun violence and gun
suicides continue to increase the need
for Action incorporation at the state
and federal levels have never been more
critical or more apparent
the current raw drives an unnecessary
wedge between State and law enforcement
worse it does nothing to make our
streets safer
as a matter of fact
it's a diff it makes it easier for
criminals to purchase untraceable ghost
guns with no serial number or to come
back combat our national and Regional
plague of illegal firearms
Granite status are tax paying United
States citizens
as such they deserve
as such they deserve to benefit from the
full protection of current and future
federal laws that will reduce the risk
of gun violence keep Firearms off out of
the hands of criminals and save lives
passing this bill and repealing the
current law would also address
unintended consequences such as chilling
long-standing corporations between
federal state and local law enforcement
opening a door to potential lawsuits and
losing Federal grant money to support
state and local law enforcement
activities
reducing the risk of gun violence and
suicide is a public safety
refusing to hand handcuff
handcuffing law enforcement from
enforcing laws that make us safer is a
New Hampshire issue and our
responsibility
thank you Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker we
passed this law last session because we
had concerns that there might be some
odd things coming out of Washington
Mrs house will be in order Mr Speaker
the ATF
told us years ago that so-called AR-15
style pistols were legal and we bought
millions of them and then they decided
one day not so much now they're illegal
this law was passed by us so that our
law enforcement would not be used as a
tool of the federal government to
enforce whatever thing they came up with
at the time
none of that's changed the weird stuff's
representative Senator natasto has
requested a roll call and it is
sufficiently seconded members take your
seats
motion before us is majority committee
report of inexpediate the legislator and
house bill 78.
it's a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative Harry at goth
speaker
if I if I know that granted status are
tax paying United States citizens as
such they deserve the benefit from the
full protection of current and future
federal laws that will reduce the risk
of gun violence keep Firearms out of the
hands of criminals and save lives and
furthermore if I know that there is a
movement within New Hampshire to take
New Hampshire out of the union and that
that this bill would help eliminate that
care recognize representative Roy for
Mr Speaker if I agree with the previous
speaker to the extent that we are all
citizens in the United States and as
such we have the protections of the
United States Constitution would I then
vote to support the committee position
the motion before is the majority
committee report of inexpeding to
legislate on House Bill 78. this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button of your opposed
you'll press the red button voting
all members president an opportunity to
vote
200 voting yay 173 voting Aid committee
majority committee on criminal Jackson
Public Safety to which those referred
House Bill 106 FN and act relative to
extreme risk protection orders
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is in expedient to legislate Senator
Terry Roy for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass Senator Nancy Murphy for the
minority of the committee chair
speaker and good morning honorable
colleagues
today I rise in opposition to the itl
motion on HB 106 a public safety Bill
drafted to provide
a tool to prevent gun violence tragedies
including mass shootings and suicides
HB 106 is identical to HB 687 which came
before this body during the 2019-2020
term through intense house criminal
justice subcommittee work and a great
deal of collaboration and Co-op
compromise HB 687 was drafted with
consultation input from many
stakeholders
uh HB 68 87 garnered bipartisan support
and passed both chambers before being
vetoed
HB 106 is before you today to address
the most extreme instances of Crisis
those situations where an individual is
demonstrating that they are a danger to
themselves or others around them and
temporarily blocking his or her access
to the most lethal means available to
inflict harm a firearm
can save lives and enhance Public Safety
gun violence tragedies that HB 106 aim
to prevent are often preceded by red
flags warning signs such as threats and
other dangerous Behavior
despite their desire and willingness to
help law enforcement and the loved ones
of those in crisis are thwarted in their
ability to perform provide prompt
meaningful
appropriate and proactive intervention
without the power to do so
without such proactive action those in
crisis as well as any potential victims
they might have remain at heightened and
unnecessary risk of harm
why does New Hampshire need a red flag
Bill like HP 106
under current New Hampshire statute a
person who displays warning signs that
they're considering suicide or engaging
in a violent act but who is not a
prohibited person under the federal gun
control act law would still be able to
legally buy and possess firearms
89 percent of all New Hampshire gun
deaths are suicides
in 2020 New Hampshire's gun suicide rate
was around 17 percent higher than the
national average suicides attempted with
a firearm are lethal about 85 percent of
the time
HP 106 is a life-saving tool that will
allow people in crisis the chance to get
the health they need and prevent those
foreseeable warning signs from
escalating into tragedy for New
Hampshire citizens
I'd like to take a few minutes to
clarify what a New Hampshire extreme
risk protective order is and what it
isn't it finally addressed
constitutionality and due process
urpo orders provide an Avenue for law
enforcement and a very limited group of
people to ask the courts for assistance
in protecting a loved one or in law
enforcement's case a Community member
who is demonstrating through their
behaviors that they are a danger to
themselves or others if given access to
a firearm
red flag bills like HB 106 authorized
courts to issue temporary urpos relative
to Firearms under very explicit and
what hb106 does
to protect Public Safety HB 106 creates
a rigorous legal process civil not
Criminal for a narrowly defined group of
persons
only family and household members an
intimate partner or Law Enforcement
Officers to petition the court for a
temporary civil order an erpo
petitioners may ask the court for an
extreme risk protective order and the
courts are under absolutely no
obligation to Grant the order
only to hear the petition
during a hearing the petition must prove
by a preponderance of the evidence that
an individual in crisis poses an
immediate or significant risk of harm to
themselves or others if given access to
that firearm
and recognizing that Firearms are the
most lethal means to cause such harm and
erpo is necessary to prevent that from
occurring
for an ex parte order to be issued
extreme circumstances must exist which
pose a real risk that irreparable harm
will result if the judge does not take
immediate action before hearing from all
sides to to the issue
the facts presented in such a pleading
requesting emergency are ex parte relief
must convince the judge that unless this
extraordinary order is issued harm will
result that cannot be remediated
this process mirrors the current
domestic violence protection order RSA
173b it is also consistent with child
protection ex parte orders here in New
Hampshire
should a judge decide to grant that
temporary order a hearing for all
parties to be heard must be held no
sooner than three days and no later than
seven days a respondent also has the
right to request an expedited hearing
it is not a criminal proceeding there
are no arrests no fingerprints and no
criminal records no one is prosecuted in
the criminal courts because it's not a
criminal matter
there's no assignment of guilty or
innocent related to the Civil order
erpos will prevent people who cause
extreme risks to themselves or others
around them from using their own firearm
to do harm and from then acquiring a new
firearm or ammunition during the length
of the order which could be as short as
three days
and the extension of an herb of an
herbal cannot exceed 12 months and will
only be granted to the petitioner if it
is established by clear and convincing
evidence that the respondent continues
to pose a significant risk of causing
bodily injury to him or herself or
others if given access to firearms
what HB 106 doesn't do
HB 106 was written to include
protections for the respondent and will
not be available as some who oppose the
bill have asserted to angry neighbors
frustrated frustrated co-workers
acquaintances friends or anyone who just
has a grudge against someone and wants
revenge
those asking for an erpo order must
swear under oath in court that their
statements are true under penalty of
perjury
HB 106 protects respondents from false
allegations and creates actually a new
Standalone criminal penalty for anyone
who knowingly files a false
orpo petition or files a petition with
the intent to harass the respondent the
new penalty which is a class A
misdemeanor can be imposed in addition
to other applicable charges
because the bill requires petitioners to
file a sworn affidavit in support of the
erpo
or in subsequent sworn testimony in
support of the petition
they would they could also be subject to
perjury charges in short filing a false
petition could be punishable as both a B
felony and an a misdemeanor the
punishment for false filing is as severe
as the punishment for having a gun in
violation of an erpo
firearm ownership doesn't change when an
erpo is issued nor does it prevent an
individual from owning a a possessing a
firearm again
when it is terminated the court order
directs The Return of the respondents
Firearms upon his request unless the
respondent is somehow at that point
prohibited from possessing firearms for
some other reason
the Nix database entry includes the
expiration date and a record of the
expired urpa will not result in a denied
response on a Nick's background check
last and most definitely not least what
about constitutionality and due process
red flag bills have been enacted in 19
States in DC
are recognized by by and meet the
standards set by the United States
Supreme Court
and have been found to be
constitutionally sound and to withstand
due process challenges in Indiana and
Connecticut courts research shows that
erpos are working and save lives
let's talk about why hb106 is consistent
with the Second Amendment and satisfies
due process
though we're often reminded that part 1
article 2A of the New Hampshire
Constitution provides that all persons
have the right to keep and bear arms and
defense of themselves their families
their property in the state let us not
forget that in the landmark case
District of Columbia versus Heller the
Supreme Court determined that the rights
secured by the Second Amendment is not
unlimited and is subject to
presumptively lawful regulatory measures
in that case Justice Scalia has made
clear that like most rights the rights
secured by the Second Amendment right is
not unlimited he noted it is not a right
to keep and carry any weapon whatsoever
in any manner whatsoever and for
whatever purpose
HB 106 is also consistent with article
2A the New Hampshire Constitution State
versus Smith says the state
constitutional right to bear arms is not
absolute and may be subject to
restriction and regulation
in the New Hampshire Supreme Court
rejected of an Article II challenge to
the New Hampshire in state B Smith the
Smith Court found that the state right
to keep and bear arms is not absolute
and concluded that a restriction of that
right is valid as long as it narrowly
serves a significant government interest
the Court held that the interests served
by the statute
or the protection of human life and
property and the statute narrowly serves
those in interest by prohibiting a
category of persons likely to be
dangerous from possessing dangerous
weapons
HB 106 satisfies the requirements of the
due process clause in the United States
Constitution the ex parte hearings
included within this bill are based upon
existing New Hampshire domestic violence
laws that courts have repeatedly upheld
against due process challenges
a pre-hearing deprivation followed by a
full hearing within a reasonable time
frame is incorporated within HB 106 and
satisfies the due process of law
required by the Constitution
in a variety of other cases the United
States Supreme Court has made clear that
pre-hearing deprivations are
constitutional especially in emergency
situations the court has recognized that
in multiple contexts that where a state
must act quickly or it would be imp
where it would be impractical to provide
pre-deprivation process
post their probation process satisfies
the requirement of the due process
clause
The Prompt evidentiary hearing and high
burden of proof evidence standard as
well as the provision of penalty for
false allegation as proof satisfactory
for constitutional objections addressing
due process in other states with similar
urpo laws
despite a reluctance by some to
acknowledge that we have a gun violence
problem here in New Hampshire we do
ask the family or friends of any gun
suicide or homicide victim
ask law enforcement and our Mental
Health Providers ask the family and
friends of those who evidenced warning
signs of impending
gun violence toward themselves or others
yet absent a bill like HB 160 and the
despite the best efforts of those who
cared about that individual
life-altering or ending action occurred
when that person got access to a firearm
watch the news look at the dedications
in high school and college year books to
deceased students who didn't live to
graduation read the obituary pages of
our local newspaper we are trying to
tying the collective protective hands of
our society when we fail to take the
most minimal action to provide families
and law enforcement a tool to protect
those in crisis and those that might
harm
I believe we can all agree that firearms
and the hands of dangerous people are a
threat to Public Safety this is common
sense it's time to now to address that
threat and put a common sense solution
into statute
please show the people of New Hampshire
we are serious about saving lives and
protecting Public Safety and press the
red button to vote against the itl so
another devotion can be made Mr Speaker
I asked for a division vote thank you
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker what we
just heard from my uh honorable
colleague friend is absolutely true it
is dangerous to let people who are
dangerous to themselves or others walk
around unchecked and aren't however
thankfully I discovered RSA 135c 27-33
we already have an involuntary
commitment process in New Hampshire if
someone is deemed to be dangerous they
can be committed for 10 days for
psychological evaluation and they will
not have firearms where they are
contained so the problem solved already
we can already do it if someone is
dangerous they talk about killing people
with suicide their family members can go
right to the court put a petition in and
they will be admitted if the court
agrees they are a danger
this law proposed is very complicated as
you just heard and it puts the defendant
in the position of having to pay for an
attorney to prove that he's not going to
do something
that's not how it works in America we
don't have the pre-crime unit if you
have not done something you do not get
charged because you might and you do not
lose your rights and property because
you might do something we have a mental
health law to take care of that
and we have the Constitution to take
care of this I ask you the Sports
representative Senator natasto requests
that are all callers that's efficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded members will
I also come to order
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of index speeding to
legislate in house bill 106. this is a
roll call vote chair recognize
representative Bradley for a
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know under current New Hampshire
statute a person who displays warning
signs that they're considering suicide
or engaging in a violent act but who is
not a prohibited person under federal
law would still be able to legally buy
and possess Firearms if I know 89 of all
New Hampshire gun deaths are suicides
and if I know HB 106 also satisfies the
requirements of the due process Clauses
in the United States Constitution and if
I know this policy has been enacted in
many communities with bipartisan support
would I now press the red button so the
itl can be defeated and another motion
can be made thank you
chair recognize representative Rory for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that all the concerns that were
just voiced are already covered in
current statute and I meant the Ohio
statutes and Mr Speaker if I further
know that we don't punish or take away
property based on what someone might do
in the future and finally Mr Speaker if
I don't care what other states do
because this is New Hampshire would I
also be in order vote in favor of the
committee to itl this bill
the motion before is the majority
committee report of inexpeding to
legislate on House Bill 106. it's a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button of your opposed
or press the red button voting stations
[Music]
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
198 vote a day 172 voting 80 committee
foreign
representative wood for a motion
I know House Bill 498 for because
reconsideration
instead of wood removes reconsideration
and the member is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker after voting on
House Bill 498 at the last session I
realized I made a mistake when I was
pressing the button I later found out
that other members also felt that they
voted incorrectly so I moved that we
revisit House Bill 498 for
chair recognize representative
Harrington
chair recognizes representative
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you for
allowing me to speak on this I would
like to see this vote the
reconsideration vote passed because I
think I've talked to people there's a
lot of confusion on exactly what goes on
here I think there's an awful lot of
people that weren't aware that uh fish
and game department is allowed to
provide to perform warrantless searches
we're not talking about the bill itself
just promotion for reconsideration and I
think I mean enough people were confused
on the issue that if we have a chance to
explain it again I think the vote may
change thank you
thank you Mr Speaker
um
Mr Speaker this bill has been before us
in one form or another since at least
2012. it's been considered by at least
six different committees in this body
several in the other body it's been
heard it's been read it's been
interpreted it's been twisted and every
committee everybody has said no
if I don't want to do this again would I
vote to not reconsider this bill so that
we can keep going thank you
a division has been requested
remember
representative hole requests a roll call
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the
reconsideration of House Bill 498 this
is going to be a roll call vote the
chair recognizes representative Poole
thank you Mr
thank you speaker
if I know that protecting animals is
important but protecting human lives is
far more important
if I know that our founders
did not agree with what was going on at
the time and
did not pass and accept
and the formation of America represents
is about to reconsider motion not the
if I know that members voted incorrectly
at our last session and would like to
if I know that this is our our one and
only opportunity to take up that
discussion
would I press the green button on the
reconsideration motion
gear I recognize representative Roy for
Mr Speaker if I know that we've
considered this bill as I said before
over many years and if I know nothing
has changed since the last time we
considered this bill and if I know not
one New Hampshire citizen asked for this
bill would I vote no to the
reconsideration so that we could move on
thank you
the motion before us is the
reconsideration of House Bill 498 this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed or press the red button voting
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
117 voting yay 100 256 voting a the
majority of the committee on criminal
justice of Public Safety to Rich Lucy
Food House Bill 216 FN enact exempting
oh
DMT that's as far as I'm going
[Applause]
from a controlled Drug Act having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is in expedient to legislate
representative David moves from Minority
at a committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass instead of John R wheeler for the
jono wheeler for the minority of the
committee
the chair recognizes
dimethyltryptamine along with many other
psychedelics
has been maligned since the 1960s when
it was all psychedelics were attached to
Vietnam War resistance and the like
but their
effects on depression addiction
PTSD a whole host of mental issues is
well documented
it's just not voluminous because the
federal government and other entities
including big Pharma have endeavored to
bury it we have something like 13
percent of Americans on antidepressants
that's according to the CDC
so right now in this room we have 50
people on Skittles and we need to figure
out why it's occurring and to move these
people off of these dangerous drugs onto
something that so DMT when we trip on
DMT let's say six minutes 20 minutes
whatever it is nobody's getting in a car
and going to drive the 7-Eleven while
they're tripping on DMT
so it's not dangerous for the reasons
cited in the the committee report no
there's no Public Safety factor in
Canterbury right now as we heard during
the testimony related to the bill
there are people undergoing therapy with
this all the time there's no reports of
any crazies running around naked in
Canterbury doing crazy things so we have
well maybe there are I haven't seen them
so
okay
I'm right next door in Northfield so
in the U.S news and World Report there's
the headline is in April 20th article of
this of 2022. in Long Run
antidepressants don't improve quality of
life
which I think we all know but we don't
really want to admit because big Pharma
tells us every time you turn on the TV
brought to you by Pfizer so
so
in another in a BBC article
they wrote while conventional drugs May
numb negative feelings quote these drugs
seem to allow you to approach difficult
experiences in your life sit with that
distress
and process them
it might be getting us something more
fundamental that was the root cause of
the problem Professor Morgan said
through that we think you can get much
more lasting change
and now I'm going to go segue to
Veterans so we all know that veterans
are committing suicide at a much higher
rate
than average Americans or non-veterans
so we've had
6100 veteran suicides in 2020 alone and
we've had 20 consecutive years
of over 6 000 veterans committing
suicide every year six thousand people
that's a huge number so what are we
going to do more antidepressants they
so veterans account for more than nine
percent of all adults experiencing
homelessness in the U.S
and 39 000 on any given day
so
I bring that up into talk about the
situation in Concord which I don't know
if you guys noticed but there's a whole
bunch of homeless people in Concord so
at the late recent delegation meeting we
were talking about this in this 300
homeless they've documented I don't know
how they they tag them but they've
counted that many and 30 have applied
for housing vouchers
so only 10 percent of them are actually
looking to kind of reintegrate into
society so let's kind of figure out why
that is
do you think maybe these people have
mental illnesses that they they don't
want to take these psych meds for so
maybe we can think about different
alternative means that are safer pure
and a one-time treatment instead of
giving them Skittles every day to take
so
uh last thing to talk about is
psilocybin magic mushrooms I don't know
what you guys are familiar with
they've been legalized in Denver
in Portland and also I just found out
where is this in Massachusetts
Somerville Massachusetts actually
decriminalized them in 2021. so
we got to kind of realize what we're
doing with and we're not dealing with
some kind of Dangerous Drug we're
dealing with something that can help
people process
psychological trauma so yeah everybody
in here wants to consider they got their
stuff together but you know what a lot
of people in this state don't so we have
to provide a means for them to do it and
I think this is a safer more cost
effective means of doing it than buying
into the big Pharma propaganda and
lifelong customer model that we
currently see
so I ask that you support this bill and
allow New Hampshire residents to Live
Free or Die and choose the treatments
that they wish
to use to treat their disorders thank
you chair recognizes
oh I'm sorry there's remember yield the
remember me inquire thank you Mr speaker
thank you representative for uh taking
the question I'm a self-avowed supporter
of psychedelics and and I'll put that
before I ask the question
are you aware of any cases of accidental
overdose at DMT in New Hampshire over
the past 10 20 30 40 I don't know go far
as back as you want and or are you aware
of any criminal arrests for possession
and or use of DMT in the state of New
Hampshire over the last 10 20 30 40 50
no I am not and neither is anyone else
thank you
Jay I recognize representative Senator
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker this bill would exempt
dimethyltryptamine DMT from the
controlled Drug Act DMT is a naturally
occurring psychedelic compound that is
found in many if not all plants and
animals including humans it's been used
for Centuries by indigenous cultures and
ceramics
star magic practices to induce spiritual
experiences
DMT is capable of inducing profound
life-changing experiences
it produces an intense experience with
Visual and auditory effects altered
perceptions of time and space and a
sense of transcending the physical world
DMT has been found to have an
extraordinary ability to transport
individuals into a completely different
realm of existence people report being
blast out of their bodies and countering
beings of different forms and
experiencing
intense spiritual Revelations that are
impossible to put into words
some describe it as seeing God or being
in the presence of a higher power
DMT has been shown to change uh have a
change in the personality trait openness
by one standard deviation permanently
and many people state that their DMT
experience is the most significant
experience of their entire life
multiple U.S Supreme courses have
already ruled in favor of churches using
DMT and recently the New Hampshire
Supreme Court ruled that a Man convicted
of possession of psilocybin was
wrongfully tried because his use in the
Psychedelic was part of his religious
practice
the court cited part one Article 5 of
the New Hampshire State Constitution
which maintains that each person has a
natural and unable right to worship God
based on their own conscious and that
that individual shall not be hurt
molested or restrained in their
religious practices
provided he did not disturb the public
peace or disturb others in their
religious worship
so this bill just catches up the rsas to
the current New Hampshire law
DMT is not toxic or addictive it's
impossible to overdose on DMT and DMT
isn't even done Often by users it's done
maybe once a year and for many it's
they'll only do it once in their entire
life
uh the and the only one and committee
the only testimony against it was uh
representative uh from the New Hampshire
State Police and he was arguing that it
could be a public it was a public safety
issue because it could create an
impaired driver
um and it's just something the police
aren't familiar with uh he didn't have
much knowledge on what the effects of
dmtr DMT actually acts immediately on
the user and will uh instantly disable
them so from physical activity so and it
only lasts like five or ten minutes with
no after a factor hangover so it's not
even possible to be driving a car
um so in conclusion I ask members to
affirm part one Article Five of the New
Hampshire Constitution
every individual has a natural and
unalienable right to worship God
according to the dictates of his own
conscious and reason and no subject
shall be hurt molested or restrained in
his personal Liberty or state for
worshiping God in the manner and season
most agreeable to the dictates of his
own conscious or for his religious
profession sentiments or persuasion
provided he did not disturb the public
peace or disturb others in their
religious worship
this constitutional Point has already
been litigated on in the New Hampshire
Supreme Court and it was found in the
case of the possession of psilocybin
that the individual was wrongfully tried
thank you Mr Speaker
navigating hearing aids can be an issue
sometimes
thank you Mr Speaker
dimethyltryptamine or DMT is a
hallucinogenic drug that is currently
classified as a schedule 1 controlled
substance under both Federal and New
Hampshire law
in our State penalties apply for making
it selling it buying it or possessing it
but because it is used by certain
religious groups for religious
ceremonies our courts have carved out a
reasonable objection for people who use
DMT as part of their religion
one of the things that we focus on in
our committee whenever we're called on
to consider legalizing any substance
whether it's a hallucinogenic a
hallucinogenic or something else there's
currently illegal is its potential
impact on public safety
our responsibility when we consider
bills like this is to balance the very
real right of individuals to control
what they choose to put into what put in
their own bodies against society's need
to minimize situations where people
especially kids can consume things that
make themselves a danger to themselves
and or to others
while there's growing evidence that DMT
may be a game-changing treatment for
PTSD and other mental illnesses
this is not a bill that carves out
special exceptions for medical usage
what HB 216 does is to effectively erase
DMT from our New Hampshire statute
so if this bill passes any limitations
on making it selling it buying it
possessing it or consuming it would
disappear in New Hampshire 60 days after
Passage
unlike some of the legalization bills
that we've seen for other substances in
this body this bill has no guard rails
to protect miners no educational
elements to promote responsible use
and no protections of any sort for
anyone who cares to use it
during the public hearing we heard
testimony that a small but significant
percentage of people who use
dimethyltryptamine
experience serious side effects
these side effects can range from a
dangerous acceleration of heartbeat in
some users some people who take it can
also experience a reaction known as
serotonin shock
this reaction can occur in people who
are already taking antidepressants
so if you combine some of the reasons
why people might want to take a drug
like DMT it might be for depression
it might be for it might be for PTSD it
might be for other forms of mental
illness you can see where serotonin
shock would be something that could
we don't dispute the fact that there are
some people who may experience benefits
but the potential for unintended
consequences at a point in time where
law enforcement our medical community
and our families are already dealing
with a fentanyl epidemic is far too
great and there is simply too many
unknowns at this point
so should we allow the use of DMT in
clinical settings the way that we do for
therapeutic cannabis
maybe but that's not what this bill does
what this bill does is simply wipe DMT
off the books in a way that is not
responsible in the middle of a fentanyl
epidemic
so what I would urge you to do is to
support the committee recommendation and
vote green to itl the bill that's in
front of us and Mr Speaker I request a
division vote does the member yield the
questions I do remember yields I mean
thank you
thank you speaker Mr Speaker are you
aware of any method given given the
situation that currently stands where we
commonly find things like Fentanyl and
cyclazine in other drugs are you aware
of any method legal method at this point
to be able to test or analyze so that
people would have any idea if it was
legalized people would have any
Assurance in what is actually in what
my under my understanding is that most
of the DMT that's produced in New
Hampshire is not uh something that's
coming in over the Border it's actually
something that's produced by by the
folks who are actually using it uh for
religious ceremonies and other people
who happen to get a hold of uh uh the
plants that you need to make to make the
drug so I think the risk at this point
and this is just off the top of my head
of it you know showing up in a pill like
xylazine does with fentanyl is is
actually pretty minimal
as a member yield a further question
yes
thank you representative Muse in your
testimony you said that the people who
took DMT may be a danger to society
could you tell us a little bit more
pointed how someone who ingests DMT and
meet someone from Another Universe
potentially is a danger to society I I
it's not the they themselves represent a
danger to society but one of the things
that we did here is that when you are
under the influence of this drug you are
someplace else you're not here
one of the concerns that the state
police rightly or wrongly expressed is
you know how quickly can you get back
behind the wheel of a motor vehicle
after you take something like this
um so part I think part of the issue you
know when we talk about uh you know the
danger to society there are some direct
risks like what happens if somebody
drives but I think you know the other
thing that we need to consider is that
this is not a drug that's been tested
much or it if at all on kids
so I mean it you know to to essentially
take the reins off of it and put kids in
a situation where they can legally buy
it
um
seems to be pretty irresponsible thing
for us to do so
so what I would say is as a member of
the criminal justice committee sometimes
it's very frustrating we get bills like
this that deal with drugs like
dimethyltryptamine and psilocybin
because we're not MediCal experts all we
can really do is evaluate the risk to
Public Safety what we can't do well is
evaluate the medical risks and and I
think if that's something that the
sponsors of the bill would like to do in
the future then I think a different Bill
a different kind of Bill going to a
different committee might be the way to
achieve it so remember yield a further
question
yes
sir Roy McGuire thank you Mr speaker
thank you for taking my question
representative
um representative we just heard that you
know this can make you launch into space
and the snozberries taste like
snozberries and all that stuff but
can you explain to us what the sponsor
put in the bill as safeguards and
guidelines to protect children because I
understand children can't buy cigarettes
now but if this past would they just be
able to buy this stuff
what the bill actually does is exempt
dimethyltryptamine from the controlled
Drug Act that's it it erases it it
doesn't quite erase it that's actually
not not quite what it does what it does
is it puts an exception in there that
basically accepts it from the control
Drug Act
so there are no guard rails on its
production on its sale who can buy it
who can sell it who can make it how
strong it needs to be whether it has
contaminants in it nothing
son of San Antonio has requested a roll
it's not sufficiently seconded this will
members take your seats there was a
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of in expedient to
legislative and house bill 216. this is
a division vote
chair recognizes representative senator
find out that DMT has no public safety
hazard
and if I know that the use of DMT is
protected by part one Article 5 of The
Constitution for religious use and that
our constitutional rights do not require
guard rails
and if I know that DMT naturally exists
in the human body
and if I further know that DMT is
reported to have people experience the
most significant experience of their
life then when I press the red button to
uh so we can make another motion thank
you
care recognizes representative Roy for a
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
don't want children to be able to walk
into the store and get a pack of
Bubblicious and some mushrooms or
whatever to trip on what I vote to keep
the motion before is the majority
committed report of inexped into
legislate on House Bill 216. this is a
division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposed you'll
press the red button if only stations
while members president an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
274 voting yay 97 voting Aid a committee
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which his
deferred House Bill 624 FN act relative
to Federal immigration checkpoints have
been considered the same report the same
with the following Amendment
recommendations to fill out a password
Amendment president they have been used
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable
agreement a majority Report with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate instead of
Jonathan stone for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is zero four one six eight
printed in house record 14 pages 40.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted
the motion before us now is all the
password Amendment the chair recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker
in New Hampshire we have an established
protocol a public notification when
sobriety checkpoints are planned we do
this not because we want to encourage
people driving Under the Influence to go
around the checkpoints
rather we aim to decrease the potential
imposition on everyday citizens going
about their everyday lives
yet until now we've allowed the
imposition of the federal government
setting up immigration checkpoints up to
a hundred miles away from the border the
actual Border in the exact same way with
no public notice
now I want you to picture how much of
our state
is within the 100 mile overlapping
jurisdiction of the U.S border Patrol in
fact it's all of it
the entire State a state where we
respect excuse me where we respect
privacy rights and the right to be free
of arbitrary stops and searches
basically the definition of a checkpoint
is subjected to the whims of the border
patrol now I understand the need for
vigilance I understand that the border
patrol has a job to do
but New Hampshire residents whether
longtime residents visitors or newly
naturalized citizens do not deserve to
be arbitrarily stopped and searched
without notice
many of our constituents also depend on
the revenue of tourists and visitors who
flock to our many attractions and events
I'll tell you right now my friends
who've come up here every year for
decades to attend Bike Week would
certainly think twice about making that
Trek at a time when they may end up
stuck on the highway for hours and risk
unreasonable searches on their ride
there
and those those times things like Bike
Week are exactly the times border patrol
casts their very wide net
to their minds this is ideal
now I'm not asking for immigration
checkpoints to end what I am asking is
for our state police to notify simply
notify the public in a post in a tweet
really however they choose
when they are made aware of a potential
imposition on the good people of New
Hampshire on their behalf in mine please
join me in passing this very simple
straightforward request for common
courtesy from our law enforcement
and I requested division book
I Rise also in support of this bill and
I'm I'm sharing my personal story
because this could happen to any of us
or any of your kids
um my father worked for the U.S
government for usaid when I was born he
was stationed in Pakistan so my first
passport photos were taken when I was 10
hours old
I've been through an immigration
checkpoint they asked to see my license
then they asked me where I was born
then they asked me to pull to the side
of the road so we could have a further
discussion
I was there for quite a while
wasted my time wasted their time it
caused a huge traffic line from all the
people waiting for me to finish
answering their questions
inconvenienced a lot of people because
my father worked for the U.S government
when I was born
so
I ask you to vote in support of this
bill of notification because if I know
that for example I'm going up to North
Conway to go shopping or if I know I'm
going up to Waterville to go skiing
although I don't choose to ski there but
if I knew I were going there to ski and
I knew that there was going to be an
immigration checkpoint I would know to
include my passport in my car that day
to save both myself and the immigration
authorities an awful lot of time
so I ask you on behalf of myself and on
behalf of any of your kids who it could
be to vote in support of this Bill thank
you
immediately
representative tensile are you in the
room
uh thank you Mr Speaker I apologize to
my concession once I wasn't aware I was
going to be speaking I am if I know that
it's not appearing I
again sorry I wasn't aware I was
but my speech is going to be very short
I am against the ought to pass on this
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this is
a bill that has been before us
in several other sessions this is a bill
that the house has generally looked
pretty kindly on there really is nothing
in the bill that keeps anybody in law
enforcement from from doing their job
there's nothing that keeps border patrol
officers from doing their job in the
bill all it really does is require
notification of a process that can
present a huge inconvenience for people
who live in the area and for a lot of
the people who fuel the economy of the
North country
uh so essentially what it does is it
puts some guard rails around
communication
but in no way does it affect the ability
of Customs and Border Patrol to actually
enforce the Border
we've had a request for a division vote
Senator roll call Representative Heinz
requester roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of autopass has amended
this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Karen Reed for
if I believe that the United States is a
Sovereign Nation I would oppose house
bill 624.
if I believe that the goal of House Bill
624 is to stem the flow of illegal drugs
and guns coming into our country I would
oppose house bill 624.
if I believe that advance notice of a
checkpoint would defeat the purpose of
having a checkpoint I would oppose house
bill 624.
our if I believe that our border patrol
agents are under attack daily and could
use support in their duties I would
oppose House Bill 624 thank you and if
you support
um
if you oppose House Bill 624 please
press red thank you chair recognize
representative Muse for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
nothing in this bill prevents Customs
and Border Patrol officers from doing
their job or prevents local or state law
enforcement from assisting them
but if I also know that immigration
checkpoint stops can put an unreasonable
burden on local residents inconvenienced
visitors who are the lifeblood of our
economy in Northern parts of the state
and are often used as a constitutionally
questionable pretext for conducting
broader searches that may violate civil
liberties then would I press the green
button to move forward a bill that
simply requires the public be notified
in the same way notice is currently
provided for sobriety checkpoints in New
Hampshire thank you
the motion before us the majority
committee report a lot of passes amended
on House Bill 624. this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press a
green button if you approach you'll
press the red button voting stations are
goodness
I need a thumbs up or a thumbs down
well members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
220 voting yay 152 voting Aid a
yourself
the committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 367 FN local
relative eligibility of students in
education Freedom account program this
comes to us without recommendation
representative cordelli moves Auto pass
as amended
we'll vote on the amendment first the
amendment is
0226 H
printed in house record 14 pages 37. are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
supposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the chair recognizes representative luno
thank you Mr Speaker
so what do we know about New Hampshire's
brand new education Freedom account
program
well we know it was highly unpopular
with granite Staters what
when it was proposed two years ago more
than 5200 people signed in opposition to
it
and the bill didn't even get out of our
committee or have a vote on the house
floor
and we know the program was designed to
provide students from low-income
families an alternative to their Public
School
but turns out just about all the kids in
the program were already in private
schools or home schools when they
applied for an EFA
House Bill 367 now amended expands the
program to include families making more
than a hundred thousand dollars a year
and now is not the time to expand this
program
this coming fall the legislative budget
office will provide will will conduct a
performance audit on the program
currently the fa program has cost
taxpayers almost 25 million dollars
and the commissioner is asking for
another 60 million in taxpayer money to
pay private school costs over the next
two years
expanding the program will reduce the
amount of funding available to our
Public Schools the schools we are
required to adequately fund for the New
Hampshire Constitution
and when the state diverts money away
from our Public Schools what happens
that's right it increases our property
taxes
bills like House Bill 367 are policy
bills
but that also says a lot about our
priorities
now is not the time to expand this
program
please consider the impact on the state
budget and how that impact will limit
the state's ability to fund other
priorities important to your
constituents all Granite Staters like
public schools
and what that will do to your local
property taxes
please vote no on the motion of ought to
pass so that a note another motion can
be made
and Mr Speaker I request a division vote
thank you
chair recognize your representative
cordelli
thank you Mr Speaker
we all know that this has been a very
beneficial program to many children
we know that children are not just
school funding units their children
we also know that parents want the best
for their children the best possible
education for their children like the
little one we've been hearing from this
morning
what we want to do is Empower parents to
provide children with those educational
opportunities
but we also know that there is an income
cap for this program
the committee amendment that we just
passed
increases by a small amount that family
income limit
we might even say that it keeps up with
the historic inflation that we've been
experiencing
we've heard testimony about hundreds of
families that have been denied access to
the program because of their income
not just denying the family but denying
the education that that child and that
family needs to succeed
currently a single mom with a child they
have an Inca income cap of under fifty
five thousand dollars
this amendment would increase that cap
so that that Mom and her child could
have an in an income of approximately
nine thousand dollars greater than they
do now
how many of those families would qualify
I don't know but we want to give them a
chance we want to give the children a
chance
in terms of the impact of this program
we heard that about the impact that this
will have on the budget
I'm more concerned about the impact in
our kids
we believe that the bill passage with
this amendment has a great chance to get
signed into law we ask you to give
support to more New Hampshire children
so that they can have the opportunity
representative Sweeney has requested a
roll calls that's efficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 367. this is a
chair recognizes representative luno for
Mr Speaker if I know that according to
the Department of Education the EFA
program was intended for students from
low-income families
and if I know that this bill expands the
EFA program to families making more than
a hundred thousand dollars a year
and if I know that expanding the EFA
program will limit the state's ability
to fund other programs important to
granted Staters then would I press the
red button to defeat the ought to pass
motion so that another motion could be
made thank you gee I recognize
representative Osborne for parliamentary
inquiries
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know this bill raises the household
income eligibility of an EFA from 300
percent of the federal poverty line to
350 percent if I know Low Middle low and
middle income parents are using
education Freedom accounts to ensure
their parent children receive the
education they deserve
and if I also know this program has
exceeded expectations providing
economically disadvantaged students
learning options to successfully fit
their personal learning needs
would I then support this modest
eligibility income level increase by
pressing the green button thank you
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 367.
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you approach you'll press the red button
[Music]
while Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
180s house will be in order 187 voting
yay 184 voting a committee report Nevada
passes amended is adopted
for what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker having voted on the prevailing
side I move reconsideration and urge the
body to vote now
a division has been requested the motion
is for reconsideration on House Bill
367.
division has been requested members take
the motion before us is re
oh
chair recognizes
representative Wilhelm for a podcast
thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to lay
the motion before us is reconsideration
of house bill 367.
it's a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button of your
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
okay
representative
fall members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
182 voting a 190 voting a the motion for
reconsideration fails
[Music]
chair recognizes representative Wilder
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to
memorialize
The Honorable Paul mursky I would ask to
try chairs of the HRA to join me in any
I came into this legislature in 1990.
we're not all going to be able to fit up
here so
thank you Mr Speaker
I came into this chamber in 1990 I
joined an active group called the
legislators for limited spending
about 1994 Along came a new member
called Paul palmersky
and he was active in the group and after
a while he said
your focus is too narrow
we should be looking at the Constitution
and the party platform and a few weeks
later he formed a different group called
the house Republican Alliance
and pretty soon I'll be LLS members went
over to join that group as well and it
has been very active since since about
1994. you see the results house
Republican Alliance has been a very
active group so I rise to memorialize
the gentleman Paul mursky who on
February 19th departed this world he was
one of the great influences in this body
for the approximately 12 years that he
was here he has left a lasting Legacy
and he's had some good friends I would
ask
let's see is Cliff Newton here
I would ask him to make a few remarks
thank you thank you Ken for that
I uh knew Paul marsky for over 25 years
and my first served with him in 2002.
and in that time
we get a lot of things done we get a lot
of the group together the HRA
and Paul had a laugh that was as big as
the man himself
and what I would need to catch up with
Paul all I'd have to do was go in the
hall or go on a floor of a room and if
he was on that floor you'd hear him
because he'd laugh
and I talked with him recently before he
passed and he had still had that laugh
Paul was also a rebel his favorite
saying was never ask for never asked for
excuse me it's easier to beg for
forgiveness and ask for permission
and Paul was telling the story about his
college days his parents had a store on
I think it was uh it was a big lake up
North Windham lake or something like
that
and his parents wanted to go on vacation
so they asked Paul who was in college
they said can you come down and run the
store and you guys and your friends you
can have whatever you want in the store
to eat and drink
and they say his father said just one
thing he said don't feed the dogs
so Paul being the rebel the store had a
little that had a popcorn machine and
every night to empty the popcorn machine
what would he do he'd feed the Ducks
so when his parents come back his father
gets out of the car and there's hundreds
of ducks on the lawn
and his father looks at him and all he
says is
you fed the docks didn't you
so I can't help but hope that Paul is
somewhere still feeding the Ducks
and still being a little bit of a rebel
[Applause]
okay
yeah
chair recognize representative Wilhelm
for a
announcement I most doing no I just
thank you Mr Speaker I just wanted to
move that the remarks Memorial marks be
placed in the permanent journal without
objection
um
we're going to take lunch let's meet
380 FM relative to non-academic surveys
ministered by a public school or a
chatted school to its students it comes
without recommendation
chair recognizes
members take his seats the house will be
the member has a right to speak the
thank you Mr Speaker
honorable colleagues I rise in
opposition to House Bill free 80.
current statute ensures that surveys are
conducted on a volunteer basis the
opt-in policy ensures that no one
participates unwillingly and no one is
pressured into participating
changing this to opt out makes parents
less aware of what is going on inside
the classroom
it is imperative that parents can easily
choose for their students not to be
surveyed
also there are New Hampshire students
underperforming on the Statewide
assessment therefore we should we must
prioritize academic Improvement and not
decrease instructional time to perform
unwanted surveys that provide no
academic benefit
the survey mentioned by name within
houseboat free 80 is the youth risk
behavior survey which has been conducted
biannually by the CDC since 1991.
while in high school I took this survey
twice
the questions are direct and invasive by
Design asking about sensitive topics
such as abuse neglect drugs rape and
suicide to name only a few
after completing the survey there is not
a follow-up to discuss these topics even
though students who feel embarrassed
scared and uncomfortable
need support
not surveys
furthermore the validity of aggregated
data must be considered
survey results lack credibility because
of a lack of honesty
for example underage substance use is a
commonly committed crime but likely
underrepresented in the data
there are even students who think it is
cool to intentionally skew survey
results
therefore conclusions made from
falsified data should be considered
misinformation
finally houseboat free 80 would apply to
Future surveys that we do not at the
present time know the content of
so please join me in opposing the OTP
motion because people are not
percentages and should not be subjected
to unwanted surveys for the sake of
collecting inaccurate data
the chair the chair recognizes
thank you and uh good afternoon welcome
back for lunch
how many times have we sat in this Hall
and heard the statement this bill isn't
ready for prime time it needs more work
where the committee needs more data
just this session think back on your own
committee votes and how you may have
concluded with a statement we need more
data we need more information then you
vote to itl or retain the bill because
you don't have it
this isn't a fancy bill it's not the
youth risk be her behavior survey that's
in law it's not what we just heard it
doesn't die on the table as an unfunded
mandate there are no hidden agendas or
unintended consequences lurking in the
shadows
it simply does a couple of things in
order to improve the collection of data
in public schools
it opens up non-academic surveys to
Charter Schools who have been omissing
this
the same parent preventions continue to
be in place prior written and electronic
notification continue to be in place
notification of parents that they can
review the survey up to 10 days before
online or in person continue to be in
place
and parents can opt out their children
from the participation of the survey if
they so choose nothing changes the focus
of this bill is very simple
expand data collection to Charter
Schools and increase participation in
all public schools so by using the
opt-out system versus an opt-in
researchers know that the more data
collected yields more results and
provides better opportunities to make
more accurate recommendations thereby
improving the effectiveness of programs
that can be offered to all of our
students at the public school
as I noted at the beginning how many
times have your committee requested more
data or more information this bill does
just that for public schools thank you I
request that you vote green on HB 380
and Mr Speaker I request a division
please
well representative Senator has
requested a roll call it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
foreign
[Music]
pass on House Bill 380. this is a roll
call vote chair recognizes
representative Ladd for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you very much Mr Speaker
if not if I know current law provides an
exception for the CDC youth risk
behavior survey for Administration in
our New Hampshire Public Schools however
if I also know this bill further expands
the exception to allow other yet to be
defined CDC prevention programs to be
administered in our Public Schools
and if I know the intent and
consequences of this bill
are an overreach and would allow further
data mining of student personal
information
and home life what's going on there
would I then press the red button thank
you
chair recognize representative Balboni
if I know the surveys like the youth
risk behavior survey provide data that
schools can use to improve curriculum
services and programs for their students
and if I know that parents receive
Advance written notification of the
administration of these surveys
they can opt out their children from
participating
and that students are not required to
answer all questions
then why would I now
excuse me then why would I now vote Yes
and press the green button to allow
student voices to be heard thank you
the motion before us the motion before
us is auto pass and House Bill 330 this
is a roll call vote for in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button the voting
[Music]
hello members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
181 voting a 193 voting a the motion
fails
for what reason is a member rise Mr
Speaker I move in expedient to legislate
motion before us now is in expedient to
legislate on House Bill 380.
Mr Speaker
that is a higher emotion so the motion
before
division the motion before us now is to
lay House Bill 380 on the table a
the motion before us is the table house
bill 380.
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative luno for a
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that that
placing this bill on the table will give
us the opportunity down the road to take
this off the table and consider how
collecting information from schools
including Charter Schools can help us
all do our jobs better would I press the
green button and put this put this bill
on the table thank you
chair recognized representative land for
parliamentary inquiry
fellow Representatives if I know the red
flag is up would I then press the red
button
the motion before us the Soleil House
Bill 380 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
181 voting yay 195 voting a the tabling
motion fails we're back to the pending
motion of inexpediate to legislate are
you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
the committee on education to which was
deferred House Bill 440 FN relative the
use of Education trust funds I'll also
be in order
this comes to us without recommendation
of cordelli moves ought to pass
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I urge you today
to reject
the o2p OTP motion on HP 440
this bill is not a housekeeping item
the education and freedom accounts or
efas as a known
has grown since this is in its Inception
two years ago
originally it was proposed to assist
families within 300 percent of the
poverty level with a taxpayer voucher to
attend a school of their choice
introduced at the time
as a proposed rate of only 25 students
at a cost of a hundred and twenty nine
thousand dollars
currently there are three thousand two
hundred students receiving an EFA
voucher at a cost of 20 million dollars
the governor has proposed 60 million
dollars in this next biennium
as you can see the funds for the EFA
program
are growing by the Millions
even though servicing just three to four
thousand students
the program deserves its own designated
budget item
the education trust fund was established
to provide needed State financial aid to
local public schools to support an
adequate education for over a hundred
hb440 would take needed funding from the
EFA away from the trust fund
to add this funding for the EFA program
from the education trust fund threatens
the amount of taxpayer trust funded
dollars to local school districts
further
there is currently little accountability
on the allocation of taxpayer dollars to
the EFA program
by designating a specific budget item
for the EFA program the millions of
dollars devoted to the program will not
get lost in the many education
department of education programs
there needs to be a stated budget limit
to the allocation of the EFA vouchers
some project that the EFA program May
exceed 70 million dollars
we need to remember that every dollar
expended from the education trust fund
is a dollar that will not go to the
adequacy aid to your local school
district
and could eventually raise taxpayer
dollars
the EFA program needs its own budget
separate from the trust fund
the education trust fund needs to remain
dedicated to the funding of adequate
education for the 160 000 New Hampshire
students attending Public Schools
I urge you to vote no
on the OTP motion of hb440 so that an
alternative motion can be made and Mr
Speaker I'd request a division vote
thank you very much
care recognized representative cordelli
thank you Mr Speaker
let me tell you really what this bill
does
HB 440 clarifies the intent of the
general court with respect to the
education trust fund the education trust
fund was set up in 1999 and specified
specific uses including Distributing the
education grants to schools
since that time a number of programs
have been signed into the law
specifying use of the education trust
fund these include infrastructure grants
and kindergarten grants to
municipalities
those statutes specifically
addressed the education trust fund as
the source of funding for those grants
two years ago the education Freedom
account program was created and put into
law stating specifically let me quote
appropriation from the education trust
fund the amount necessary to fund any
grants or transfers authorized under
this chapter is hereby appropriated to
the department from the education trust
fund
HP 440 adds efas and these other
programs as authorized uses of the
education trust fund
due to oversight
the education trust fund statute was
never updated to include these programs
but isn't it interesting that during
testimony the only one of these programs
that was objected to was the education
Freedom accounts as we've just heard is
it possible that this is really just
another attempt to
attack the education Freedom accounts
there are two legal principles in play
here
first
and we've heard it before
one legislature cannot find a future
legislature
thus the 1999 legislature which defined
the uses of the education trust fund
cannot find the 2021 legislature that
created the EFA account
and said that EFA
funds are to come from the education
trust fund secondly
in 2012 the New Hampshire Supreme Court
heard a case involving the Wolfeboro
firefighters versus the town
in that case there were two statutes in
conflict
the New Hampshire Supreme Court ruled
that when there are two statutes in
Conflict the later statute controls in
this case the EFA statute
this I'm afraid is just another attempt
to mean as a means to sabotage the
education Freedom accounts
and the kids in the program
vote uh green please and Mr Speaker I
Senator cordelli has requested a roll
call vote as that's sufficiently second
that it is sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call vote members take
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 440. this will be a roll call
vote the chair recognizes
representatives cascadden for a
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that there are 3 200 students
receiving education Freedom accounts
vouchers costing 120 million dollars
and the proposed rate for the taxpayer
funded voucher was originally for 25
students at a cost of 129
then wouldn't we propose a separate
state budget line item
if I know that there's a dire need to
fund Public Schools would I not allocate
property tax dollars for that purpose
and if I know that there is little to no
transparency and accountability of our
local property tax dollars funding
education Freedom account programs what
I now vote no by pushing the red button
chair recognize representative
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this bill is necessary to
update the statute for the use of the
education trust fund and if I know that
one statute cannot violate another and
if I know that when a conflict exists
between two statutes the latter statute
will control and above all
this is a really boring bill because all
we're doing is updating statute would I
motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 440. this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
191 voting yay 185 voting a
the committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 464 FN relative to
eligible students in the education
Freedom account program comes to what's
without recommendation Senator Felicia
lakis moves ought to pass chair
thank you Mr Speaker
the education Freedom account or EFA
program is in its second year of
operation
and started out with an income limit of
300 percent of poverty which was about
ninety thousand dollars today we just
entertained a bill that raised it to 350
000 which stretches that limit up to
almost a hundred thousand dollars for a
family of four
the initial intent of the program was to
provide school choice for low-income
families to send their children to
private and home school as an
alternative Choice from a public school
families whose children were already
attending private or parochial schools
or were home schools immediately took
advantage of this new program
their numbers were unknown when the
final initial final statement physical
statement was made and only 20 to 25
percent of the funds actually went to
the students leaving the public schools
that's why there was such a discrepancy
the resulting cost of the program was
grossly underestimated both in the
number of the students and the resulting
amount of money that would be taken from
the educational trust fund there's still
no budget cap to the allocations to the
afo EFA program
this bill proposes new eligibility for
the FAA program with no income
requirement by extending eligibility to
include groups of students who were in
various categories and situations
the families of these children are from
situations like foster care
children with disabilities migratory
children English language Learners and
more categories which would now be
eligible to receive EFA funding without
any
income limit
the number of students in these
categories would be added to the program
and the number is totally unknown
what we do know is that these are the
very students who would greatly benefit
from the expanded Services they could
receive in the public school system the
private and parochial schools are not
required and in many cases do not have
the research sources to offer
these vulnerable students and their
families need a strong safety net meals
basic needs
specialized school programs and
Specialists community services and the
inclusive and nurturing culture found in
local communities Public Schools
to make such drastic changes in the
eligibility for the efas at this point
by expanding to an unknown number of new
students without any new income limits
or a cap on the total amount will once
again balloon the costs of the program
we should think long and hard before we
expand the EFA program and its effects
on our educational trust funds at this
point because adequate funding for our
Public Schools needs to be this
legislature's top priority
I requested division vote please and I
urge everybody to vote itl on this
motion thank you gee I recognize the
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
and thank you house members good
afternoon
I want to ask you to go on a little
imaginary trip with me
who's your imagination
so imagine for a moment that you've
showed up as a new rep
and you've gone through all the things
necessary to get elected and here you
are
and you get your first bill and you're
looking at it and it's like
you can't really it's like it's all in
code and you can't figure it out
so you ask and you're told now this is
how you read these bills and this is the
word you're really going to want to know
shall shall make sure you know this see
it looks like this memorize this this is
what it looks like okay so you think you
got that one and the first bill comes up
and you still can't
decode this but all right
you've learned look at the pictures
there aren't any pictures
you've learned listen to what other
people are saying well they're saying
things they're talking about schools and
they're talking about students and
they're talking about discipline and
you've read the bill and it's got this
word that says Lash
Lash
okay
but it doesn't have that other word that
word the other word they told you that
said May
that's the other important one challenge
May
well this other bill has this word
that says
yam
doesn't make sense
but lash is teachers
and
discipline lash are we going back to
lashing students so you speak out
because
we're now going to be lashing students
lashing students and everybody
and and you say that and now they're
making fun of you you show up at the
cafeteria and what's going on you show
up at the cafeteria and they're calling
you lash and you hear your name coming
up and now this is your suspend I
we're kind of getting a little off base
here on
trying to explain the situation of the
children in our schools
so you're a student and you don't get it
and it's not working and you go to your
teacher and it's not working and they
say I told you read from left to right
hold your hands like this the one that
makes the L and you go they're all L to
me I don't get it
but you're still not getting help and
now the kids are making fun of you
what's this got to do with the bill
yeah I think it has to do with bullying
and special needs the representative
the member was raised the point of order
State your point of order yeah yeah I I
believe we've veered way off of the
content of of this of this bill which is
basically to um to remove any income
eligibility for certain groups of
students uh who apply for the education
the member kneels to really needs to
concentrate on the bill itself not
what's in this bill
our kids with special needs
and kids who are being persistently
bullied
those kids go to their parents and they
say can't I get out
a mandated to go here and the parents
say I don't have enough money
and the kids say well but so and so we
have more money than they do
and the kids you know well yeah but they
have helped the state pays for them
because they don't make much money the
state isn't going to pay for us well so
and so got help they went to this
special school and now they can read
yeah but their parents have money
but we have money we're not doing too
badly yeah but we have to fix the roof
and the car needs to be replaced
and we don't have money and everything
but guess what you still have to go to
that school we heard stories I can't
tell you how many kids coming in
parents coming in their kids with belly
aches throwing up in the morning
anything to avoid going to school and
being bullied again
it doesn't make sense to them they can't
decode the words they can't read it
makes no sense
when Dad came and told us that story he
said but I have money
I took my kid out
I put him in a private school he's doing
excellently and my son said to me Dad
what about all those kids whose parents
don't have enough money
are they still having to go through
stuff like I did
and he came and said I don't want an EFA
for me I don't need it but I want an EFA
for all those kids
those kids who are being bullied those
kids who just aren't getting it and
aren't being reached by the the school
system
I want them to be able to go to a school
that meets their needs a school that
teaches them how to decode those words
that make no sense to them
and that's what bilis is about
Mr bride stability for those kids who
are being moved all over the place so
they can use their EFA to go to one
single school instead of being moved
every time they're in a new foster home
or their parents get transferred
that's what it's for it's for those kids
and I ask you we don't know where those
families are and we don't know where
that line is we don't know what they're
going through but I ask you to support
those kids so they can get the help that
the parents who have lots of money can
provide thank you so remember yield to
questions
sorry I always yield to questions
does the member yield the questions yes
so thank you for taking my question
um
is is it true that this bill does much
like what we do in Medicaid where there
are Financial eligibility requirements
to establish need as well as
categories in which people can qualify
based on their need as well beyond just
the financial I is it true that this
establishes some categories in which the
need of the student is as important as
the financial wear with all of the
parents
yes it is thank you very much
just remember yield to further questions
I do
we're Adele you may inquire
thank you Mr speaker thank you member uh
for taking my question
um we've talked in the education
committee a lot about
um
students in schools that are not
succeeding
we've talked about students that are
persistently bullied
are those students
in addition to the ones I think you
mentioned in foster care and special
needs children are they all included in
this bill as
students who would not have to be
subjected to the income cap of their
family
yes there are a number of categories and
they're all listed in our calendar under
my talk and they were mentioned by the
other representative who spoke before me
thank you very much
the motion before us is the auto pass
motion and house bill 464. it's in a
senator has requested a roll call it is
sufficiently seconded members take your
seats this will be a roll call vote
foreign
motion before us is the underpass Motion
in House Bill 464 this is a roll call
vote chair recognized representative
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues and I must say it's a
pleasure to be able to stand here and
say that
if I know this bill attempts to expand
the education Freedom accounts program
far beyond its original intent despite
the program lacking accountability
academically or fiscally
and if I know that the budget for the
program has already been exceeded by
millions of dollars and making this
drastic change in eligibility will
further balloon the cost of the program
without any limits on the cost to our
taxpayers
and Mr Speaker if I know that funding
Public Schools adequately should be this
legislator's top educational priority
would I now press the red button to
oppose the OTP thank you
gee I recognize representative dry for a
if I know that efas can offer stability
to children who are moved around a lot
like children in foster care or children
in military families and if I know that
many children now in this state in EFA
programs fall into the categories that
are listed in this bill
like having special needs
or being persistently bullied
and if I know that there are other
children in similar circumstances in
this state
whose middle class families can't afford
alternatives
but make just enough to not qualify for
an EFA
Mr Speaker would I then vote to join
with the intent of the governor's budget
and extend this education opportunity to
these marginalized children
by pressing the green button now
the motion before us is the ought to
pass Motion in house bill 464. it's a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button to be a poser
press a red button voting stations are
[Music]
members president had an opportunity to
192 voting a 184 voting a the motion of
Water Pass passes
does it memorize Mr Speaker having
voting on the prevailing side I move
reconsideration and urge the body to
vote now
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill 464 where a division has
been requested I would assume all
just
the motion before us is the
reconsideration vote on 464. this is a
division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
fall members president an opportunity to
181 voting a 196 voting a the motion for
reconsideration fails
for what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker having voted on the prevailing
side of HB 440 I move reconsideration
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill 440 this is a division
vote
if you're in favor you'll vote you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
181 golden a 195 voting a the reconsider
uh what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker having voted on the prevailing
side of HB 380 I move reconsideration
the motion before us is to reconsider
house bill 380. this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
of all members present and an
opportunity to vote also attend the
179 voting 897 voting May the reconsider
foreign
the majority of the committee on
Judiciary which was referred House Bill
112 an act relative to tenants right to
notification prior to the sale of a
multi-family home having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ochsu pass with Amendment
representative Zoe Manus for the
majority of the committee
the amendment is 0252h President house
Amendment
I did not
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexperienced to legislate
representative Joe Alexander for the
minority of the committee
the question is on the committee
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
gotcha his subdivision before I even
reached for it so this will be a
all right the question is on the
committee report
this is a division what
yeah it's on the email sorry I was
watching somebody wandering around while
the question is on Amendment zero two
five two H if you're in favor of
adopting the amendment you will press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
today
[Music]
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
179 on the affirmative 194 and the
the question now is on the motion of
the member from Goffstown representative
Alexander is recognized to speak against
the committee report
thank you Mr Speaker I'm going to make
this very quick
HP 112 would require the owner of a
restricted rental property and just so
everyone knows restricted means four or
more units to give a 60-day notice to
tenants that the landlord or housing
provider intends to sell the property
60 days is way too much time in this
housing market and it removes the
ability for a landlord to entertain any
cash offers because typically a cash
offer you can close less than three
weeks so further restricting the housing
Supply restricting rights of the
landlords uh to flip and sell their
property will exacerbate the housing
crisis everyone knows the housing crisis
is a supply side issue and further
regulation would not solve it
so and just to clarify this committee
Amendment now with this bill in place
with the amendment not passing means
that
um
the the owner has to give a good faith
offer to the tenants and they have to
entertain the offer from the tenants
before they can accept any other offers
so with that energy committee to vote
red things the house of all red thank
you
the member from Durham representative
Kennedy has recognized to speak for the
uh thank you Mr Speaker
HP 112 would simply say that tenants
must be notified 60 days before the
final sale of the building they live in
this applies only to restricted
multi-family buildings the kind that are
owned by corporate landlords this does
not apply to small private landlords
renting out a single home or a couple
adus or the like this is nothing more
than a right to know for the consumer
the person renting
currently prospective buyers will often
jump through hoops to keep their
purchase of the property a secret
knowing that tenants simply simply knew
the truth about what was happening to
the property they may make preparations
including potentially using their free
market ability to leave the committee
heard testimony from tenants at some
prospective landlords in conjunction
with the seller have inspected the
property before a sale by claiming they
were insurance adjusters others claim
that they owned a neighboring property
and had questions about the property
line
the majority of tenants in this state
are month to month extensions of their
original lease a change in ownership
might mean an immediate rent increase or
changes to a whole host of policies that
have been in the month-to-month
agreement
but even for tenants who are still
finishing out their lease at the time of
transfer a new landlord can mean changes
to aspects of the property that were not
guaranteed in the lease
so the language of the original bill
came directly from current New Hampshire
RSA in the 1980s New Hampshire passed a
very similar law for the notice of sale
in regard to mobile mobile home parks
the law went further than this bill does
or would have if amended
the result of the law has been that
tenants were able to organize together
and put in offers to buy their own
property
today we have
189 successful community-owned mobile
parks in the state as a result of that
law
organizations that help tenants band
together to get funding as Co-op have
formed for this very reason
this change has been productive and as
we have empowered the tenants with
information at the beginning we turn
tenants into the owners
something that has across the board
positive impacts on communities and not
only that but the sellers by including
the tenants up front were able to get
better offers for their properties
meaning the changes are good for the
tenant
and the sellers to conclude HP 112
simply says the landlord will notify
their tenants 60 days before the final
sale the vast majority of Dales do not
close within 60 days anyway this is a
completely non-honorous business
practice that would simply uphold the
basic right to know and good free market
principles rather than keep people in
the dark about what is going to happen
in their homes which is currently
happening therefore I urge my colleagues
to support the OTP motion thank you Mr
Speaker
representative Stanton assassin was
requested a roll call vote which is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members please take your
seats
the question is on the motion of ought
to pass on House Bill 112 this is a roll
call vote
representative Tripp is recognized for
if I know this bill requires the owner
to provide tenants with a notice of sale
and the first writer refusal on purchase
of the property
and if I also know that if less than the
total participation by the tenants
reduces the probability of their being
able to obtain financing
and if I know that an existing lease
protects the tenants from eviction by
the new owner
and if I know
that this bill diminishes the property
rights of the owner would I then vote
red
representative wheeler is recognized for
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that all HB 12 112 does is allowed
tenants to know when their property is
going to be changing hands and if I know
that this has been done for decades in
this state with regard to mobile homes
with great success and if I know that in
essence this is a basic right to know
Law Without which the free market cannot
work and the market is currently shifted
in One Direction and finally if I know
that not only is it far from onerous to
Simply inform people of what's happening
to their homes but it actually helps
sellers get better offers when they
include tenants in the process when how
often dismiss potential buyers would I
now press the green button to agree with
the majority of the committee's report
the question is on the motion about to
pass on House Bill 112 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
to press the red button voting stations
[Music]
of all members president had the
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
175 in the affirmative 199 and the
negative the motion fails what reason
does remember rise Mr Speaker I move in
expedient to legislate representative
Sweeney moves in expedient to legislate
on House Bill 112 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed name
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
the committee on Judiciary to which was
referred House Bill 170 in relative to
the termination of tenancy at the
expiration of the tenancy or lease term
comes to us without recommendation
the member from Portsmouth
representative mcbeath is recognized to
good afternoon
so the landlord tenant bills you're
going to hear today this is the real
sleeper
this bill will repeal
hb117 will repeal a statute that is 38
years old
it came out of a study committee that
the governors established in 1985 I just
want to remind you that is when the
ozone hole was first discovered in
Antarctica Super Mario Brothers were
introduced and Ronald Reagan was
President so it's been around a long
time and it's done a pretty good job
if this bill passes it will remove the
limited protections that tenants have
once they've established a tendency and
it only applies to larger landlords
people with four units or more
doesn't apply to commercial doesn't
apply to owner occupied or vacation
recreational boarding houses but it does
require that at the end of a tenancy
which is 12 months or six months
anything over six months that the
landlord can't just arbitrarily end the
tenancy can evict the tenant has to have
a good cause and good cause could be any
legitimate business reason or some of
the reasons that you know of or her bad
tenant reasons not paying rent Etc
so this has been around for a while in
2005 the New Hampshire Supreme Court as
is mentioned in the little um report
upheld this law
and all the five justices voted yes they
wanted to uphold it one Justice said he
wanted to uphold it for a different
reason
um
in making that decision the Supreme
Court said that if we repealed these
statutes these protections good cause we
would eviscerate the protections for the
tenants in these units
and some of the consequences that they
said relationships with friends and
neighbors would be destroyed children
would have to change schools and there
would be loss of support system for
elderly so um I'd like you all to please
uh vote
um against red of the OTP so that
another emotion could be offered thank
you
the member from Windham representative
Lynn is recognized to speak in support
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues in order to explain why the
enactment of hb-117 is important
let me ask you all to participate in a
brief quiz in which you answer to
yourselves a single multiple choice
question
assume you own a small you are a small
landlord owning rental properties
perhaps three or four units and you
don't own you don't live in the property
and one of your units is up for rent
and you decide to rent the property to
it to a tenant for say for for one year
for say two thousand dollars
so now the question
what's the term of the lease
a one year
be forever
see one year for the tenant but forever
for you as the landlord
that the answer is a one year seems
obvious doesn't it I said the least
specifically says it is for one year so
that must mean the term of the lease
contract is one year right
wrong
the answer under New Hampshire law as it
now stands based on the 2005 Supreme
Court decision that was referred to
earlier is C
the term of the lease contract is one
year for the tenant but it is forever
for the landlord
stop and think about that
a single contract has one meaning for
one party to the contract but an
entirely different meaning for the other
party to the contract
this completely unprecedented violation
of basic contract rights results from
the Supreme Court's conclusion that the
termination of a tenancy does not
constitute good cause for evicting a
tenant who does not want to leave
the rationale for the Court's decision
was that the landlord's contract rights
really are unimportant in the case of
restricted property because the only
thing the landlord should be concerned
about is getting paid and having a
tenant who who does not damage the
property or disrupt any other tenants
therefore as long as the tenant does not
violate these requirements the tenant
can stay for as long as he or she wants
of course this rationale does not work
both ways at the end of the lease the
tenant is free to move out without any
adverse consequences whatsoever
the weakness of the Court's reasoning in
the case was pointed out in the
concurring opinion of Justice Joseph
Neto who I will note was a Democrat
appointed to the court by Governor
Shaheen
Justice Netto wrote and I quote
under the majority's interpretation
lease Provisions purporting to limit the
lease to a specified duration have no
meaning
the effect of the majority's
interpretation is to create a Perpetual
tenancy virtually a life interest in
favor of a tenant of restricted property
covered by the statute I do not believe
that that was the intent of the landlord
tenant statutes
the Court's decision was ostensibly made
to protect Senate's rights in reality
however the decision has the effect of
reducing the availability of housing to
those most like the who are most likely
the most vulnerable
consider the landlord who must decide
whether to rent to a tenant that appears
questionable maybe the tenant has a
spotty credit history or a contentious
personality that may mean he or she
might have problems getting along with
other tenants
if the landlord knows that a one-year
lease means what he what it says he
might be willing to take a chance on
that person knowing that the maximum
period of exposure is one year
but under the law as it now stands the
landlord knows that if he rents the unit
to the person he may be stuck with that
person forever
as a result the landlord in all
likelihood will decide not to take the
risk which means that this person will
not get the housing he or she needs
the bill does contain an exception for
very short-term leases of six months or
less because in such cases there usually
is an expectancy by both parties that
the Senate will be extended for at least
the six-month period
please restore the law to what it should
mean that property rights are important
that contracts mean what they say so
that landlords are not discur and so
that landlords are not discouraged from
renting to people who do not fit the
model of the ideal tenant thank you and
Mr Speaker I respectfully ask for a
the question is on the motion about to
pass on House Bill 117 representative
Lynn requested to never mind
representative Santa nostalzo requests a
roll call vote which is sufficiently
seconded there shall be a roll call vote
the question is on the motion about to
pass on House Bill 117
representative Marjorie Smith is
I know
that state law requires that a landlord
have good cause for eviction non-payment
of rent
substantial damage to the apartment or
taking the apartment off the rental
market or substantially renovating it
if I know that the New Hampshire Supreme
Court
recognizing that when judges are
appointed
one hopes that they have forgotten the
political party of the governor who
appointed them
if I know that the New Hampshire Supreme
Court has ruled that expiration of Elise
is not good cause on its own
for eviction if I know that this bill
denies tenants the protection of the New
Hampshire's well constructed eviction
law would I now press the red button so
that another motion could be made thank
you Mr Speaker
representative Lynn is recognized for
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill will correct the law to eliminate
the situation whereby a lease provision
specifying its term is rendered a
nullity for the landlord but is fully
enforceable by the tenant
and if I know that the court decision
that produced this result violates the
contract and property rights of
legitimate business people who provide a
valuable public service by making
housing available to the public
and if I know that the law as it now
stands reduces the availability of
housing to those who are likely to have
the most difficulty in securing housing
then would I support OTP for this bill
by Crest pressing the green button thank
you Mr Speaker
the question is on the motion of ought
to pass on House Bill 117 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
again
the ball members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
211 having voted in the affirmative 157
the committee on Judiciary which was
referred House Bill 401 relative to
evictions based on the owner's intent to
renovate the property comes to us
without recommendation
representative Marjorie Smith moves
the member from Londonderry
representative Perez is recognized to
thank you Mr Speaker
I too will be very brief because House
Bill 401 does not work
when did we as legislators get into the
business of controlling Property Owners
of their fundamental right to control
how and when they can renovate their
property
when did we as legislators
decide we had the right to tell Property
Owners when they were allowed to rent
their property
this bill will both discourage
development
and Rehabilitation of property
and upgrading individual Apartments
both are needed to sustain economic
growth in New Hampshire
why would we possibly want to restrict
apartments from being able to being
available for a period of time
when we have a critical housing shortage
and why would we possibly want to find a
landlord for putting his property up for
rent when it is ready
this makes no sense
this bill is a lose-lose for all
involved
the property owner as well as a
potential
against
trust but verify
the representative from Durham uh
representative Kennedy is recognized
speak in support of the motion
thank you Mr Speaker I will also be
brief because this bill would easily
work and is completely reasonable uh
this bill offers needed protections and
increased notice for tenants and
situations where landlord plans to
renovate property or remove property
from the market under this bill when an
eviction notice regards an intent to
renovate a renter must be provided 60
days notice to vacate be told what work
is being done on the unit they are
renting and an accurate time frame that
the renovation will take
additionally it must be shown the work
will take longer than 30 days and cannot
be done safely if the tenant remains
living there
if the eviction is based off the owner's
intention to remove the property from
the market this bill would require 60
days notice and that the unit is off the
market for one year this is to ensure
that the reason offered for the eviction
is in good faith and the tenants have
adequate notice
and time to secure housing so in short
this bill provides a very fair balance
where a landlord can still renovate
their property or remove their property
from the market but also offer
reasonable protection so tenants have
stability and more opportunity to find
alternative housing I urge my colleagues
to support the OTP motion thank you Mr
Speaker
the question is on the motion about to
pass on House Bill 401 representative
Samson Nostalgia requests a roll call
vote which is sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call vote members please
see
you
the questions on the motion about to
pass and House Bill 401 this is a roll
call vote
representative Wallace is recognized for
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that house bill 401
would place an unnecessary additional
burden on our landlords and if I further
know that in the current rental housing
market requiring a landlord to keep a
rental housing unit off the market for a
year would only worsen the availability
of units and finally Mr Speaker if I
know that ultimately this bill would
likely result in higher rental rates
representative Kennedy is recognized for
you miss speaker uh if I know that this
bill offers a fair balance between a
landlord's right to renovate property
and remove that property from the market
and a tenant having adequate notice to
avoid these very difficult situations if
I further know that this bill will
ensure evictions are done only in good
faith than what I now press the green
the question is on the motion about to
pass and House Bill 401 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button if you're opposed press the
red button voting stations are open for
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
154 in the affirmative 213 in the
negative the motion fails for what
reason does the member rise Mr Speaker I
move in Expedia into legislate
representative Sweeney moves in
expedient to legislate be ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
the committee on Judiciary which was
referred House Bill 469 FM prohibiting
discrimination against tenants holding
certain vouchers for purposes of renting
dwellings comes to us without
recommendation
representative Horrigan moves out to
pass
the member from Windham representative
kuchab is recognized to speak against
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker New
Hampshire is in a housing shortage and
we need to encourage new landlords to
enter the market not force existing ones
out with new regulations
House Bill 469 would forcibly require
landlords to participate in the section
8 housing Choice Voucher Program rather
they want to or not
landlords would be compelled into
entering into a 12-page government
contract without any say in the content
of that contract
they'd be involuntarily obligated to
comply with 77 pages of program
regulations which place many burdens and
additional costs onto the landlord this
would undoubtedly exasperate rents
a provision of this bill which allows a
landlord to be excluded if their rent is
higher than the rent Allowed by the
program
would undoubtedly encourage rent
increases
we need to fix the Section 8 program and
incentivize landlords to want to
participate in the program not force it
upon landlords
please vote not no on not to pass so
that a note another motion can be made
thank you
the member from Durham representative
Kenny is recognized speak in support of
thank you Mr Speaker
so this bill regards individuals who
participate in the housing Choice
Voucher Program which are more commonly
known as Section 8 vouchers under
current law landlords can refuse to rent
to a voucher holder for no other reason
other than the fact that they hold the
voucher without knowing anything else
about the tenant currently here's the
reality for many Granite Staters who
either currently hold a voucher or are
waiting for one
first an individual may be on the wait
list for up to nine years because there
are so few available then after
receiving the voucher they only have 60
to 90 days to secure housing or they
lose the voucher but here is the issue
after waiting several years to receive
the voucher uh
they are put in the situation
where landlord just continuously say no
for that sole reason they lose their
vulture they remain homeless in our
housing crisis worsens
so what does this bill do
simply this bill would not allow
landlords to discriminate against
prospective tenants for the sole purpose
that they hold the voucher in other
words it allows the tenant to just get
their foot in the door that's it there's
plenty precedent for such a bill
including every other New England State
this is because typically the holders of
these vouchers are either elderly or
disabled and they're individuals who are
the most vulnerable and should be
despite what you might have heard this
does not force a landlord to accept any
particular applicant over another just
because they hold a voucher additionally
there are exceptions under this bill
where landlords would not be impacted
including when the Housing Authority
determines that the dwelling fails to
meet the housing quality standards under
HUD meaning if the dwelling does not fit
the standards required the landlord is
exempt and they are not forced to comply
with the regulations Additionally the
bill excludes landlords whose rent is
higher than the program allows
and to continue that sentence from the
bill and the rent charge for the
dwelling unit is the same as the
landlord charges tenants for a
comparable unit in the same building or
Housing Development so there is no
incentive to raise rent
thus the bill and the exceptions create
a very fair and reasonable balance
between protecting vulnerable Granite
status by giving them a chance instead
of their current impossible situations
and landlords who still remain fully in
control of who they rent their property
to I urge my colleagues to support OTP
thank you Mr Speaker
does the member yield for a question
did you know that in fact people who
have such vouchers to rent have a longer
longevity at his place than those
without such vouchers and therefore
questions on the motion about to pass on
House Bill 469 representative requests
say roll call which is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
the questions on the motion about to
pass on House Bill 469
representative Wallace is recognized for
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that house bill 469
would require landlords to accept
Section 8 vouchers and if I know that by
doing so compliance with 77 pages of
federal regulations and a 12-page
housing assistance program contract
would be required and finally Mr Speaker
if I know that the provision allowing a
landlord to be excluded from the
rental rate excuse me the requirement to
accept Section 8 followers vouchers due
to the rental rate of a particular
rental unit is higher than the rent
Allowed by the Section 8 program
could lead to rent increases in order to
be excluded from the program where now
press the red button to keep the free
representative De Lorenzo is recognized
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that HUD encourages
landlords to screen voucher holders the
same as they would screen any other
applicant in that screening includes
prior landlord references
credit checks and criminal background
checks and income verifications for all
adult members of the household
and if I know that a landlord is not
obligated to rent to any applicant that
fails to meet the landlord tenant
selection standards
further if I know that the landlord is
not obligated to accept a HUD voucher
amount lower than the HUD allowed fair
market rent for the unit
than what I press the green button and
vote O2
the question is on the motion about to
pass on House Bill 469 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button opposed press the
red button voting stations are open for
representative
all members present had an opportunity
to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
165 in the affirmative 206 and the
negative the motion fails for what
reason does the member rise Mr Speaker I
move in expedient to legislate
representative Sweeney moves expedient
to legislate on House Bill 469 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
[Applause]
the committee on Judiciary to which was
referred House Bill 567 relative to
notice of rent increases in certain
residential property comes to us without
recommendation
representative munz moves ought to pass
and offers amendment to zero four two
nine H Princeton House record 14 on page
39. the questions on the amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
the question now is on the motion of
ought to pass
remember from Windham representative
kutchab is recognized to speak against
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
this bill requires that landlords
provide at least 30 days written notice
of any rental increase for
non-restricted properties and 60 days
for restricted properties
in the case of an increase which exceeds
15 percent a written notice of six
months would be required
the tenant could then terminate the
lease with only 10 days notice to the
landlord
further regulations of the time and
manner in which rent is raised will
burden the property rights of landlords
cause landlords to raise the rents to
offset the additional burdens imposed by
this bill and do nothing to solve the
housing shortage in New Hampshire
please vote no on OTP so that another
motion can be made so that we can
prevent this step towards instituting
the member from Durham representative
horrigan's recognized to speak in
thank you very much Mr Speaker
um
so I Rise to speak against uh
HB 567 and this is against the bill is
as introduced one of the objections the
previous
member had was to something that
actually would have been taken out by
the amendment but that I support the
bill either way so it's um
not a rent control bill it's a red
transparency build
and landlords can still raise tenants
rent but they now can no longer do so
without advance notice noticeably it's
60 days advance notice some small
landlords should only be required to
give 30. and these deadlines which I
think are modest are probably only
increases the less than 15 percent
increases of 15 percent or more would
require six months notice and 15 is more
than double the current rate of
inflation which according to most recent
numbers is 6.4 percent
and uh so I know that uh something we
did here during the Heritage frankly is
this does prevent landlords from raising
the rent to cover unanticipated expenses
although the actual specific
possibilities we were told about the
hearing were actually things that can be
easily anticipated and planned for
um
just routine operating costs being
higher than expected the occupancy rate
for rental housing is almost 100 percent
it literally rounds up to a hundred
percent from whatever 99 Point whatever
six percent I think it is
they're twice with the average family
could pay those prices are high for many
reasons I don't think it's because the
law is too tough in the landlords and I
don't actually don't think it's also the
rising cost of Maintenance so can you
hold up for a sec if you guys want to
have conversations there's a really nice
room out there for the member has a
right to be heard okay oh thank you Mr
Speaker
and um
so I think we have the right to expect
landlords like any other business people
to uh you know manage their businesses
properly in a way that's fair uh for
their customers the tenants and also
fair for themselves
anyway you can we can if this bill does
pass
um the landlord can still raise the rent
by more than 50 percent they just have
to wait more than six months for the
increase to take effect
and I'm giving the market the way it is
they can probably get it so finally also
we heard about the free market during
the pi for the previous Bill rental
housing market no way resembles the free
market we all learned about it econ 101
I assume probably most of us took some
version of econ 101
but it still can't function properly
unless both sides of the transaction
that what the price will be
so this bill simply provides price
transparencies I think it's a
so I urge you all to uh
Luke green and Pastor Bill as as
a number another member from Durham
representative Kenny is recognized to
speak in support of the motion
thank you Mr Speaker uh last time I'll
be up here today I promise uh so HB 567
is a simple build that requires uh
tenants are given additional notice in
certain situations when rent is being
increased instead of the current law
which only provides 30 days in every
situation this bill increases the notice
uh of an owner of a restricted
residential property that they must give
60 days but owners of unrestricted
residential property would remain at the
current 30-day notice so in other words
this bill would only impact owners who
are in the business of renting property
but not truly smaller landlords also
without the amendment this bill requires
six months notice for rent increases
that exceed 15 percent of rent in effect
at the time of this notice 15 which is
an egregious increase uh it's this
strikes a fair balance between ensuring
landlords still have their right to
raise rents while protecting tenants in
reasonable situations and from
unambiguously egregious increases as we
all know we are experiencing a housing
crisis in New Hampshire this puts
individuals in impossible situations
where without adequate notice of
significant rent increases they may
realistically not be able to pay not be
able to find more income and most
certainly not find new housing as it
would nearly be impossible in such short
timelines that are under current law
this is not rent control this is a
reasonable measure that gives Granite
Staters more time to plan in budget
instead of being stuck in impossible
situations so I urge my colleagues to
support the OTP motion thank you Mr
Speaker does a member yield for a
question
the question is on the motion about to
pass on House Bill 567 representative
Samson Nostalgia request a roll call is
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
[Music]
regular
okay
questions on the motion of ought to pass
on House Bill 567 this is a roll call
vote
representative Wallace is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that house bill 567 is an obvious
step towards rent control and if I
further know that the bill requires
owners of restricted properties to
provide 60 days to six months notice of
the owner's intent to raise the rent as
a function of the percentage of the rent
increase and if I know that after
issuance of the rent increase notice the
tenant needs only provide 10 days notice
of intent to vacate and end the lease if
the tenant so chooses and finally Mr
Speaker if I know that once again
passage of this bill will likely lead to
higher rents would I now press the red
representative De Lorenzo is recognized
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that tenants of
owner occupied or small properties
deserve at least a 30-day notice of rent
increase
and if I know that tenants of large
properties deserve at least a 60-day
notice of any rent increase that is more
than 15 percent of the current rent
if I know that these notices allow the
tenant time to find other housing if
they feel they are unable or unwilling
to pay the increased rent amount then I
would push the green button in vote to
questions on the motion of ox pass on
House Bill 567 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor press the green
button if you're opposed press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
members present had an opportunity to
vote
the house will attend to the state of
166 in the affirmative 207 and the
you got to stop meeting like this
you're going to start talking
representative Sweeney moves in
expedient to legislate on House Bill
567. are you ready for the question
it's a division vote for members take
clear
the question is on the motion of
inexperience to legislate on House Bill
567 this is a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button if you're
opposed press the red button voting
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote
I also attended the state of the verb
and a shocking turn of events 208 and
the affirmative and 168 and the negative
I'll also be in order
majority committee on Judiciary to which
was referred House Bill 647 FN
act relative to causes of action for
individual rights having considered the
same report the same the falling
resolution we saw that as inexpeding to
legislate
representative Joe Alexander for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority of Report with
the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment General Marjory
Smith from a minority of the committee
uh for what reason does it member rise
for a motion Mr Speaker motion I moved
motion is in order
division has been requested the motion
members take their seats this will be a
the motion before us is to lay House
Bill 647 on the table this is a division
vote
if you're in favor you will press the
green button of your opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
for 333 voting yay 37 voting nay I
believe that the majority is to lay it
majority of the committee on Municipal
and County government do which was
deferred House Bill 51 and act relative
to requiring towns and school districts
use warn articles for lobbying agents
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution result that is
inexpeding to legislate
Senator Jim megliore for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee have it
considered the same you know agree with
the majority report the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass from the
Josh ocella the minority of the
committee
the house will be in order the member
has a right to be heard
thank you Mr Speaker
thank you fellow
Representatives
I forgot that this bill was mine and I
wasn't going to speak but somebody else
gave it to me anyway
while the voters of a district elect the
board of Selectmen School Board Etc the
interest of the voters are not identical
to those of the board
using tax money taken from someone to
lobby for something that the citizens
may strongly disagree with is the sort
of activity that the courts have found
to be compelled speech it is wrong
this bill just requires that the voters
in the town School District Etc vote to
approve the spending of local tax money
on lobbying
restricting the use of State money for
lobbying is under RSA 15 colon 5. State
money cannot be used for lobbying
obviously
currently no recipient of a grant or
appropriation of State funds may use
those funds to Lobby the legislature
it this bill allows local tax money to
be spent on lobbying if approved by the
voters
this is the lease that should be done to
protect the people from lobbying from
for issues that maybe they may disagree
with
and then the nhma and New Hampshire
School Board Association spend a lot of
time here in the house lobbying lobbying
a lot of times for
stuff that is against
the voters
but for the people that paid us salaries
this this bill says neither Warren
article so the people the voters know
that they are spending local money for
lobbying
so please join me in pushing the red
button so a correct motion may be made
thank you
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues
as we just heard this bill will demand
RSA 15 colon 5 to require towns and
school districts to use a warrant
article for the approval of each and
every lobbying agent that might assist
the town in understanding the impacts of
legislation
requiring the Warren article for each
agency that lobbies for and or against
legislation is absolutely impractical
and would severely impede the ability of
local officials and legislators to
effectively manage the Prudential
Affairs of their communities and
therefore I urge you
to support the strong bipartisan vote of
itl
by pressing the green button
supporters of this bill argue it is
needed to ensure transparency about the
cost of lobbying efforts and to ensure
that voters have a say into whether they
want lobbying efforts at all
but this transparency already exists
organizations that Lobby already
register and file quarterly Financial
reports with the New Hampshire Secretary
of State and these are readily available
in multiple forms on the Secretary of
State's website
RSA 3217 also requires that a line item
detailed budget be provided to the
budget committee for consideration and
this would include any dues to any
member organizations proposed in the
operating budget Appropriations can also
be contained in separate warrant
articles either by the governing body or
um all this information is readily
available to the public and the voters
the legislative body can then amend or
zero outline items
for such items through the annual
meeting process or vote these warrant
articles down outright therefore voters
already have the information as well as
the power to make decisions on
memberships to these organizations that
means this bill is not really about
transparency it's about state government
micromanaging the authority of local
voters and officials
much of the discussion in committee was
focused on the training education
advocacy support and lobbying efforts
provided by the New Hampshire Municipal
Association an organization well known
throughout Concord
we all know that our towns operate
Upton's operations would not be as
efficient or cost effective without
membership to the nhma
there is no other means to get the
comprehensive service and support for
local officials at nhma provides
but we should not forget that there are
many other membership groups like The
Town clerks Association The Tax
Collectors Association the New Hampshire
planning this planners Association and
many many many more which provide
training education and advocacy that
would be adversely affected by this
legislation
these groups are incredibly helpful for
small towns with limited funding that
might not be aware of pending
legislation and that could have
consequential effects
and how beneficial I remember member
organizations that assist legislators
towns and City officials and Municipal
Department employees here are some
comments from the municipal and County
Executive session on this issue what's
wrong with lobbying
it's not a four-letter word if lobbying
means getting information that I need
then it's useful information as a public
official I need that information
our local school board chair was a
member of the School Board Association I
really don't know how you can delineate
discussions of those members who sit on
those boards from what is educational
versus what is lobbying
now I'm a select board member and
there's hardly a meeting goes by when
someone doesn't say that we should get
input from an HMA
I don't feel that nhma is lobbying at
all I can go tell them to jump off a
cliff
I have seen it how nhma has represented
themselves as providers of information
and it is not a lobbying for these
reasons colleagues I urge you to support
the overwhelming
bipartisan itl vote of 15 to 5 by
representative Sana natasto has
requested a roll call vote it is
sufficiently seconded members take their
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpected to
legislate in house bill 51. also be in
order
this will be a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Alicia Lucas
if I know that many associations are
able to separate their fees relating to
information and training from those
relating to lobbying and if I know that
these lobbying organizations work for
the best interest of their members but
not necessarily that of the taxpayers
and finally if I know that using tax
money taken from someone to Lobby from
something that person may strongly
disagree with is the sort of activity
the courts have found to be compelled
speech and is wrong would I then press
the red button so another motion baby
babe thank you
chair recognized resident status for
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the committee
rejected this bill in a 15-5 bipartisan
vote
and if I believe that it's important for
us as legislators to understand how
local government works and to understand
the concerns of local officials
and if I know that organizations like
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
provide valuable information to us even
if I don't always like that information
and if I believe that local voters
should be allowed to decide how they
want to spend their tax dollars without
interference from the state would I then
press the green button to accept the
committee report thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us the majority
committee report of inexpensional
legislator and House Bill 51 is the roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button it'll be opposed or
press the red button voting stations are
foreign
president had an opportunity to vote
224 voting yay 148 voting a committee
committee on Municipal and County
government to which was referred House
Bill 90 relative to Municipal planning
master plan this comes to us without
recommendation
Representatives Davis moves ought to
pass
sure
thank you Mr Speaker HP 90 would add two
new sections to an already extensive
list of suggested items that might be
considered by those charged with
developing Master plans
so first of all let's look at what the
current RSA contains and that is a
couple of paragraphs the first one that
begins with the words shall include and
gives a brief accounting of a few items
that must be part of the master plan the
second paragraph begins with the words
may include and then continues to list
as of now 18 items that are suggestions
for considerations the words may include
are important in this instance because
it indicates they are merely suggested
rather than a list of restrictive
limitations to be considered
one of the two new items this
legislation aims to include reads
a transition to renewable energy section
which includes an analysis of citizens
needs for alternative sources of energy
such as
EV charging stations and hand Spike
Lanes Community power generation and
incorporation of solar and wind power
into the area under jurisdiction
many of us on the that are opposed to
this uh this motion I believe that is
simply not needed
in fact instead of a never ending and
growing list of suggestions as a lot of
these bills tend to do or rsas tend to
do this entire RSA section could be
reduced to a single paragraph in the
future
one that gives those responsible for the
master plan the ability to consider any
relevant topic
thereby eliminated all the other
suggestions in the current RSA I ask you
to oppose the OTP motion so another
motion can be made thank you Mr Speaker
here I recognize representative
statements
Mr Speaker a lot has changed since most
New Hampshire towns and cities developed
what are now their current Master plans
many municipalities are probably gearing
up to beginning a new planning process
Master plans don't dictate anything they
don't have official standing as legal
documents but they do provide an
essential conceptual framework for towns
to Envision their long-term needs
HP 90 comes at an important moment a
moment when those Master planning
processes just getting underway must
adapt to dramatic change while
preserving the essential characteristics
of the towns and cities they serve
adding the chapters that hb90 proposes
will help towns address changes in
housing needs energy use and
distribution new modes of transportation
and a host of other factors that we
can't even yet anticipate
you've heard that this bill makes
unnecessary additions that perhaps a
dozen years ago it was quite
comprehensive
but that was a dozen years ago
hb90 gives towns guideposts in planning
for a future that looks very different
than it is now and when they need to
begin anticipating today
colleagues at their best master plans
provide a connection between buildings
social settings the environment and the
people who live in those settings
they are not and should not be immune to
change and in fact one of their most
important roles is to guide that change
in ways that are consistent with how
people want their towns to look and feel
the language proposed in hb90 gives
planners more flexibility than they've
had in the past flexibility to adapt to
a changing environment
but hb90 also retains the master plan's
most important function
to guide towns and cities in becoming
places that people love
places that can adapt to change while
preserving the things we all cherish
so while it's only got not only a
guidepost a blueprint if you will and it
doesn't dictate any particularly form of
land use regulation
hb90 proposes that planners do what
planners do best plan for the future
while preserving the history values and
environments that make New Hampshire the
place we love so much
I hope you will support this bill not
for what it will do right away or even
tomorrow but for how it will help our
towns and cities adapt over time to
changing conditions without sacrificing
the qualities that make them so
has requested a roll call is that
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
there
also be in order
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 90. this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative turcotte
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know the
current 16 suggestions contained in the
land use master plan RSA are just that a
laundry list of suggestions and if I
also know that adding a new suggestion
such as those proposed are totally
unneeded and finally Mr Speaker if I
know that those responsible for master
plans can already consider everything in
the current rsas as well as the proposed
new legislation negating the need for
this legislation would I now press the
red button so another motion can be made
thank you Mr Speaker
do you recognize representative Holland
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
house bill 90 AIDS municipalities in
developing evaluating and revising their
Master plans and if I know that the nine
Regional planning commissions are
releasing detailed housing assessments
and if I know this will inspire many
communities to reevaluate and examine
their Master plans would I push the
green button and help them in that
process
motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 90. this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
foreign
[Music]
had an opportunity to vote I also attend
1676 148 193 voting a the ought to pass
motion fails for
what
what reason to remember rise a motion Mr
Speaker State motion motion uh in
expedient to legislate
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate
for what reason does the member rise to
make a motion Mr Speaker
motion I make a motion to table hb90
the motion
it's in order the motion is a proper
motion motion before us is the table
house bill 90.
a division has been requested members
chair recognize representative status
for
a motion before us is the table House
Bill 70 chair recognized representative
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill would have
helped planners plan far in advance for
things that may not be able to
anticipate now
and if I know that Master plans are
essential in guiding the process and
keeping towns the way we love and
cherish them
will I now press the green button
to
approve the tabling motion thank you Mr
Speaker recognize representative wind
turcott for parliamentary inquiry thank
you Mr Speaker if I know there's another
motion more appropriate that needs to be
made would I now vote press the red
button on the tabling motion
the motion before is the stable house
bill 90. this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you opposed you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
well
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
179 voting yay 192 voting May the motion
to table fails we're back to the motion
of inexpeding to legislate are you ready
all those in favor say aye
opposed me
[Applause]
majority of the committee on Municipal
and County government to which was
referred House Bill house will be in
order
it's referred House Bill 154 an act
relative to the adoption of Public
Health ordinances by municipalities
consider the same report the same with
the recommendation that bill ought to
pass Senator Diane power for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
falling resolution resolved that is
inexpeding to legislate Senator Jim
magli are we for the minority of the
committee
the chair recognizes representative
Gilman
thank you Mr Speaker
honorable colleagues I rise today in
opposition to the motion of ought to
pass on House Bill 154.
to be clear the bill applies to all our
towns not our cities
Town Public Health officers are
appointed by the Department of Health
and Human Services they are not elected
officials
the select board which is an elected
body
recommends someone to DHHS who then
decides
if the person meets their standards and
qualifications and if so the person is
appointed to serve the town
Public Health officers in towns do not
act alone they cannot pronounce
regulations or ordinances as edicts
regarding public health concerns
under the current RSA 147 colon one any
regulation a Town's Health officer
recommends must be approved and adopted
by the town's select board
RSA 128 colon 3 provides that the health
officer and with the select board
constitute the local Board of Health and
they shall meet as frequently as needed
to review the state of local public
health issues
these meetings are where regulatory
ideas are tossed around
not adopted
these meetings are noticed and open to
the public
RSA 41 colon 14-b titled the adoption of
amendments of town codes and ordinances
says that in towns with 10 000 or more
inhabitants the select board shall have
the authority to establish and amend
Town ordinances after they hold two
public meetings at least 10 days apart
not more than 21 days apart
provided however upon written Petition
of 50 registered voters presented to the
slip board prior to their vote the
proposed Town ordinance shall be
inserted on an article for town meeting
so legislative bodies in large towns are
already protected and having giving the
opportunity to vote as a body to
pass a new ordinance
if this pill is intended to address
concerns in smaller towns then it should
say so and remember at this time the
health health officer is Not Elected and
cannot act alone
another flaw with this bill is the use
of the word special meaning
under RSA 39 colon 4 special meetings
the Selectmen when calling a special
town meeting shall within one week after
after posting the warrant
cause a copy of the said warrant to be
published in a newspaper of General
circulation in said town
within one week
so if the charge if there is an emergent
public health issue that causes the
health officer to recommend a regulation
and the select board agrees when would
it be voted on
acting in good faith a slipboard make
post a warrant for a special meeting
within the with the exact language of
the ordinance
within hours of making the decision to
have a special town meeting
the date of that special meeting has to
be after the warrant is advertised in
the newspaper this may just be a couple
days but it's certainly not the 24 hours
is represented in the majority report
plus sb2 towns have to have two meetings
so that will be even longer
if the purpose of this bill is to ensure
the legislative body has a direct vote
on proposed Public Health regulation the
24-hour notice will depress the turnout
of those voters that are being trying to
be protected
and then let's talk about the logistics
and costs if a special town meeting is
called for in sb2 towns taxpayers will
foot the bill for the unexpected costs
of setting up the polling place paying
poll workers supervisors of the
checklist and printing ballots and
having two meetings
small towns with a traditional town
meeting can move more swiftly but will
still need to meet all the same legal
requirements of an annual town meeting
Town regulations are a collaborative
Endeavor in this case the legislative
body elects the governing body the
governing body recommends a public
health officer to the Department of
Health and Human Services
DHHS appoints the officer the officer
answers to the governing body who in
turn answer to the legislative body
the changes proposed by this bill are
unnecessary to protect a Town's public
health and for these reasons I ask you
to vote no on the motion of ought to
pass so that another motion may be made
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in support of the committee
recommendation of ought to pass on House
Bill 154. this bill requires that any
new health ordinances made by a town
Health officer must be approved by a
majority vote of the legislative body
instead of by the governing body for the
ordinance to take effect
we heard in committee that this bill is
dangerous and that it would create
public health hazards to be clear such
claims are not based on fact and are
misleading the facts are as follows
first this bill does not change the
statutory powers and duties of town
Health officers for example under RSA
128 a town Health officer shell and
force Public Health laws and rules they
shall conduct sanitary investigations as
required by the Department of Health and
Human Services and they may investigate
and if necessary take action to prevent
further pollution of any aquifer a body
of water this bill does not change these
authorities of a town Health officer
under RSA 141 regarding the duties of a
town Health officer
a town Health officer shall assist DHHS
and shell enforce all rules and orders
issued by the commissioner relative to
isolation and quarantine of people in
the town
the town office Health officer shall
enforce all orders issued by the
governor in the event of a public health
emergency and they may assist the
commissioner in investigations this bill
does not change these authorities of a
town Health officer
under RSA 147 regarding health nuisances
a town Health officer shall investigate
all nuisances and other causes of danger
to the public health present in any
building vessel or enclosure and they
may make regulations as necessary to
ensure the safety and adequacy of septic
systems in accordance with RSA 147 colon
1. this bill does not change these
authorities of a town Health officer
under RSA 48a regarding rental housing
standards a town Health officer shall
enforce minimum housing standards for
rental properties if they've been
designated as a minimum housing
standards officer by the governing body
this bill does not change these
authorities of a town Health officer
under RSA 170 regarding child care and
Foster adoptive Home Inspections a town
Health officer May inspect facilities
used for child care in the homes of
foster adoptive parents to ensure a
local Health codes are met this bill
does not change these authorities of a
town Health officer under RSA 200
regarding school health and sanitation
inspections a town Health officer May
inspect public and private school
facilities to certify that they meet the
New Hampshire Department of Education
standards this bill does not change at
these authorities of a town Health
officer second this bill doesn't change
the statutory powers of the state
government and state agencies to provide
timely emergency responses for example
under RSA 40 colon 45 the governor May
declare a state of emergency and issue
emergency orders a town Health officer
does not make these ordinances does not
make ordinances addressing these issues
the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services issues drinking
water advisories such as boil water
orders and do not drink orders Des also
issues air quality the action days when
air pollutants are at an unhealthy level
for sensitive persons and also public
beach advisories when contaminant counts
exceed State Standards a town Health
officer does not make ordinances
addressing these issues the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services is responsible for public
health and is assisted by Town Health
officers Town Health offices provide
current information about the incur
occurrence transmission and prevention
of communicable diseases in their towns
a town Health officer does not make
ordinances addressing these issues
finally
what this bill does change is the
approval Authority for any new health
ordinance from the governing body to the
legislative body the timeliness of
approval is virtually the same such
approval by the legislative body can
happen very quickly if needed since a
special meeting can be noticed by the
select board and held with a 24 within
24 hours under 190 a notably until the
recent pandemic RSA 147 colon 1 had not
been previously used by towns during the
pandemic select boards in these
particular towns that use this statute
held public meetings and allowed public
input regarding new health ordinances in
conclusion
this bill does not affect the powers and
duties of a town Health officer and this
bill does not affect the ability of
state government state agencies and
local emergency responders to deal with
an emergency
therefore this bill does not create any
public health hazards this bill gives
the legislative body in a town the
authority to adopt any new health
ordinances which is the same Authority
given to voters in adopting other local
ordinances
for these reasons I urge my fellow
colleagues to support the committee
recommendation of ought to pass by
voting yes on House Bill 154. thank you
for what reason is a member Horizon
to make a motion Mr Speaker motion I
wish to table HP 154
that is a prop that is a proper motion a
division has been called members take
is
the motion before us is a table House
Bill 154 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative it's not this
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill extends the very long arm
of Concord into our very local health
issues
and if I know that that is the very
definition of overreach would I not
press the green button to support the
tabling motion thank you Mr Speaker gee
I recognize representative power for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that is
it that it is important that this body
votes on this bill
in the committee recommendation today
and not table it would I know vote no to
oppose the tabling motion and push the
red button
the motion before us is a tabling motion
for house bill 154. this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
okay
foreign
members president an opportunity to vote
180 voting a 191 voting nay the tabling
motion fails we're back to the original
motion of ought to pass on House Bill
154 president
has requested a roll call that is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
clear
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of Auto pass on House
Bill 154 this is a roll call vote the
chair recognized representative 11 for a
thank you very much Mr Speaker it's been
a while since I've been here you all
look great do me one favor deep breath
in
out through your mouth
keep doing that all day
if I know that this bill
will be costly and time consuming
and if I know that this bill
has checks and balances between the
Public Health officer in charge
the Department of Health and Human
Services the local town and ordinance is
already in place
that whenever work needs to be done
these folks will be able to talk to one
another wouldn't I then
join me in voting
no
pressing the red button thank you
Geo recognize representative power for
parliamentary
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill does
not affect the powers and duties of a
town Health officer or the ability of
the state government state agencies or
local emergency responders to respond to
an emergency in a timely manner and if I
know that this bill simply gives a
legislative body in a town the authority
to adopt any new local Health ordinances
would I now vote Yes to support the
committee recommendation of ought to
pass and push the green button thank you
Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of autopaths on House
Bill 154 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your opposed will press the
red button voting stations are open for
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
192 148 180 voting a committee report is
adopted
for what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker I move reconsideration and urge
there's a motion to for reconsideration
on else Bill 154
this will be a division vote a division
has been requested members
the motion before us is a
reconsideration motion on House Bill
154. this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposed or press the red button
foreign
opportunity to vote house will attend to
177 voting yay 195 149 that the motion
majority committee on Municipal and
County government which was referred
Hospital 177 act relative to the
definition of qualified structures under
the community revitalization tax relief
incentive considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
result that is inexpedient to legislate
Senator Josh Ocala for the majority of
the committee
the minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass president Laurie stavis for the
minority of the committee the chair
thank you again Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker this bill seeks to expand RSA
79e the statute that provides a tax
relief incentive to those who bring
dilapidated buildings and the
communities around them back to life
79e has restored economic Vitality to
many New Hampshire communities while
protecting environments that are
important to their histories and
traditions
but the law as it currently stands
HB 177 seeks to improve the statute by
extending its benefits to properties as
well
why might this be important it's
important because it's not always just a
structure that needs to be restored
most of the time those structures sit on
neglected
litter-covered lots lots that we all
avoid but are incredibly valuable in
knitting together our town and City
centers
stabilizing these Lots will bring added
benefit more opportunity for economic
activity and provide a greater incentive
to developers who seek to revitalize
neighborhoods
79e is one of the memorable suspend
if you need to have a conversation
please take it in the back room as
members that are having a hard time
hearing so please the member has a right
to be heard
take your conversations in the back room
thank you Mr Speaker
79e is one of New Hampshire's great
legislative success stories
it's brought neglected buildings back to
life infusing new Vitality into towns
across our state
adopting HB 177 will expand on that
success provided badly needed relief to
those who take on the risk of
rehabilitating blighted properties
I urge you to overturn the itl
recommendation on this bill so that
another motion may be made
we should do all we can to support
initiatives that preserve our Collective
history while bringing New Life to
communities
we should reward those who invest in
revitalizing those communities by
allowing them access to the tax release
hb's 177 offers and we should build on
the current statute successes and extend
those to properties that can bring
economic and cultural revitalization to
our town and City centers thank you Mr
Speaker
Geo recognize the representative Lynn
turricot
thank you Mr Speaker HBC 177 would make
changes to what is called the community
revitalization tax relief incentive
program the first change would allow
land now to be given the same tax relief
that is allowed given or currently given
to structures only the section change
which is kind of important would allow
for the extension of the geographic area
from current downtown and City centers
to any other area of the municipality
legislation creates several problems the
first one when you hear the words
incentives and tax release should raise
a few red flags and probably the hairs
on the back of your neck the first
decision to give is it allows the
discretion of a few officials to Grant
these incentives and tax relief secondly
these same individuals determine who
gets the tax relief and for how long
this is subjective to terminate
determination and it's ripe for special
interest and favoritism next and the
most important as with any of these type
of programs the tax burden is shifted
from most taxpayers who will see their
taxes go up while tax relief is given to
a select few
lastly to enact the original tax relief
program that's contained in the irsa it
required the taxpayers approval through
a warrant article or by a recorded vote
of the municipalities legislative body
adding this provision would bypass that
approval process and automatically
convey convey this subjective authority
to the municipal officials
the legislation is ill-advised for all
the previous reasons and I ask that you
concur with the majority report by
voting this HB 177 inexpedient to
legislate and I also request a raw call
vote Mr Speaker
representative requested a roll calls
that's efficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
I also come to water
the motion before us is a majority
committed report of inexpany the house
will be in order members take your seats
the motion before us and majority report
of inexpinning to legislate
on House Bill 177.
the chair recognizes representative
priests for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr uh speaker
if I know infield development is in its
simplest form is the development or
Redevelopment of land that has been
bypassed remained vacant or is an
underutilized as the result of the
continuing development process
if I know that infill development may
play a critical role in providing
affordable housing which will reinforce
the downtowns of cities and town centers
and offer and an alternative to urban
sprawl and if I know that HB 177 expands
the RSA
79-e the community revitalization tax re
relief incentive by replacing the term
qualifying structure with qualifying
property so that land in the zones
adopted by the municipalities are
eligible for tax exemption under the
statute would also qualify
would I now press the red button to
oppose the itl of HB 177
so that we can offer another alternative
do you recognize representative Lynn
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this
legislation would transfer the property
tax burden to many for the benefit of a
few and if I also know that unlike the
original program in the irsa's this new
carve out would bypass the Warren
article or public body approval process
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
giving further subjective Authority for
tax relief for land as well as
structures beyond the city center and
historic districts is well beyond the
original intent of the act itself would
I now press the green button and find
this legislation in expedient to
legislate thank you Mr Speaker the
motion before this is inexpedient to
legislate in house for 177 is the roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
foreign
[Music]
McMahon
uh the sign doesn't help me singer thank
you
thank you
ball members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
under 94 voting a 170 voting a the
committee report is adopted the next two
bills are going to be roll call votes if
everybody can stay in their seat this
will move along a lot quicker
[Music]
majority
majority of committee on Municipal and
County government to which was deferred
House Bill 467 FN in act relative to
public playground accessibility have
been considered the same report the same
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass Ms David priests for the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee have been considered the
same being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpeding
to legislate instead of thy in power for
the minority of the committee
chair recognizes the representative
McMahon
thank you Mr Speaker
and good afternoon members
I rise in support of
house bill 467. this is the bill
if you've all read it IT addresses
playground facilities
and specifically for the language to be
interpreted correctly
it is for facilities to be built
so it's not an obligation prior it's for
those who are planning for these types
of entities going forward
the reason I'm for this I do have a
history of doing it myself in my town of
Windham
and it's providing access
for handicapped individuals for all ages
I know when it's a playground it's not
just
the activity for young people it's also
for what I call aggressively mature
adults our elders
who many many times accompany family
members for accessibility and getting
them out of the home and with their
friends and to be able to get to a place
without a difficult challenge before
them
title two of The Americans with
Disabilities Act since 1990 has
precipitated an opportunity for this to
take place and for us to plan to provide
this access
and it's to promote Cooperative
collaboration in a constructive
participation with family members and
those of those family members that have
handicaps
and with that being said this reasonable
modifications and the the big issue that
we have with playgrounds and also public
facilities for active and passive
Recreation
is many times they're using soft
materials you know for for walking and
in this case the designs to allow for
wheelchairs
uh crutches Walkers is a solid material
and some of the commentary just in
closing is that this is not restricted
to rubber mats it's also for strong
materials with minimum maintenance and
that can be cement tiles Etc as so
chosen by the developer within the town
in meeting this challenge
so with that with that being said and in
the interest of inclusion
for those who do not have the physical
Mobility that all of us that the
majority of us here have and they have
accessibility to town facilities
I'm asking for your support for house
bill 467. thank you very much Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
opposition to the committee
recommendation of ought to pass on House
Bill 467. this bill requires that all
public playgrounds constructed on or
after January 1st 2024 have rubber
Pathways to and from the playground as
well as to each piece of playground
equipment
the minority of the committee concluded
that this bill is inexpedient to
legislate for a number of reasons first
to be clear the issue at hand is not
about denial of civil rights instead it
is about putting into state law a
specific material constraint for
playground design which is currently
addressed at the federal level
presently under federal law any
renovated or newly designed and
constructed playground must comply with
the 2010 Americans with Disabilities Act
Ada standards for accessible design
according to Ada in addition to
providing a range of play experiences to
individuals of varying abilities in
accessible playground must have an
accessible path from the edge of the
play area to each piece of equipment
constructed from surfacing that is
compliant with the American Society for
testing and materials standard ASTM
1951.
this standard specifies appropriate
materials for surfacing Pathways under
and around playground equipment that
meet Ada's accessibility requirements
second by specifying a single type of
surfacing material this bill has a
number of unintended consequences
by prohibiting the use of other
appropriate materials compliant with
Ada's ASTM 1951 standards The Spill
unnecessary limits design flexibility
based on existing site conditions
increasing the top cost of the project
at taxpayers expense
as a result this bill May discourage the
construction of new playgrounds in the
state
this bill also forces towns to purchase
imported Rubber products despite the
fact that better domestic products may
be available
furthermore this bill does nothing to
address existing playgrounds third and a
further concern is the safety issue with
regards to the use of Rubber products on
playgrounds numerous ongoing safety
studies may result in future Federal
Regulations requiring the replacement of
rubber surfacing on playgrounds
this would result in further added
expense to taxpayers in addition to the
adverse health and safety concerns is a
negative environmental impacts of using
rubber surfacing on playgrounds which
also needs to be considered
in conclusion this bill is not needed
since playground accessibility is
already required under federal law this
bill clearly presents a number of
negative unintended consequences and
most importantly
this bill constitutes an unfunded State
mandate on schools on towns and schools
and violation of the New Hampshire
Constitution part first article 28a for
these reasons I urge my fellow
colleagues to oppose the motion ought to
pass by voting no on House Bill 467.
thank you Mr Speaker
you Mr Speaker
I Rise to speak for the motion to ought
to pass HB 467.
in New Hampshire children with
disabilities and their families
constantly experience barriers to
enjoying their basic human rights and
inclusion in society their abilities are
overlooked their capacities are
underestimated and their needs are given
low priority yet the barriers they face
are more frequent as the result of the
environment in which they live as the
result of their impairment
these objects these barriers in public
buildings transportation and Recreation
facilities continue to be a problem
this bill seeks to amend
RSA 155 by adding a new section
requiring any public playground in the
use on or after January 1st 2024 to have
an accessible Pathways made of resilient
rubber or compositive surfacing or
similar solid
surface material
this bill would complement the federal
Americans with Disabilities Act
standards the majority voted of the
community believes that improving
accessibility will make public
playgrounds and parks in New Hampshire
more inclusive and welcoming to all
children and caregivers especially those
with disabilities
in addition adding Pathways made by
these materials would relieve towns of
the need to level or replace the less
accessible materials periodically and
would save money over time
the vote was ten to one
if my fellow Representatives believe as
I do in the New Hampshire Constitution
article one that all men are born
equally free and that includes children
with disabilities
that I would press the green button and
support HB 467 thank you Mr Speaker
representative Sana natasto has
requested a roll call that is
sufficiently seconded members will take
their seats this will be a roll call
vote
the motion before us the majority
committee report of water pass in House
Bill 467 also be in order
this will be a roll call Road
care recognizes representative power for
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this bill is unnecessary since
federal law already requires that any
renovated or newly constructed and
designed playground must comply with the
2010 American with Disabilities Act
standards for accessible design and if I
know that this bill violates part first
Article 28
a of our New Hampshire Constitution as
an unfunded mandate when I now vote no
to oppose the committee recommendation
of ought to pass and push the red button
so that another motion can be made thank
you Mr Speaker chair recognize
representative Gilman for a
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the typical
playground surface in New Hampshire is
wood chips that do not maintain a smooth
traversable service surface
and if I know that devices made to
assist people with disabilities and
able-bodied individuals devices such as
wheelchairs canes Walkers strollers they
do not operate well or at all over wood
chips and if I know that equal access to
Fresh Air exercise play and
socialization are part of a person's
Healthy Growth life whether they need
assistance or giving Assistance or just
having fun would I then press the green
button and vote HB 467 as ought to pass
thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before is majority committee
report of ought to pass on House Bill
467 it's a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button to
be opposed or press the wed Breton
gone
members president had an opportunity to
vote household attended state of the
vote
193 voting yay 180 voting native
Mr Speaker
for what reason to memorize having voted
on the prevailing side I would like to
move reconsideration and urge my
remember most reconsideration on voice
sick
foreign
is the Reagan Center House Bill 467 this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button your
opposed will press the red button voting
[Music]
represent McCarter
well members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
177 voting a 196-1480 reconsider motion
fails
enjoyed the committee on Municipal and
County government to associate House
Bill 477 in act to prohibit Municipal
inspections of owner-occupied units of
multi-unit housing have been considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpeding to legislators in the David
priest for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass from the Josh rokalo for the
minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
Berry
thank you I uh in the infamous words I
many of you may not know that cities and
towns have the ability to pass what are
called certificates of compliances
certificate compliance for rental
properties what this is is a function
where the municipal the municipality can
come in and inspect rental properties to
make sure that people aren't like
slumlords and stuff like that don't have
a huge problem with that quietly kind of
on board with that
but what is kind of shocking is that the
law can be read that they can actually
inspect any property on the possibility
that you could rent it and I know this
because it happened to me
so I I own a duplex in the city of
Manchester I rent one side I live in the
other I had to get my COC renewed we
scheduled it they came out and inspected
my tenants property no problems they can
say all right now I have to do yours and
I said well why do you have to do mine
I'm not renting it I live in it they
said oh well you could rent it and I
said well you could say that about any
piece of property and they said well I
guess you could so I said that's a
problem
so I brought forward this piece of
legislation it's limited to four units
or less because four unit or less uh
properties are treated more similar to
single-family homes
um and they I don't believe anybody
testified against maybe one person
um it's pretty simple
not opposed to the inspection of the
rental property am opposed if it's owner
occupied if the owner moves out and
wants to rent it they have to get it
inspected but if they're living in it it
is your home the government has no right
to come in there and just arbitrarily
inspect it you can make arguments about
inspection about sheds about anything if
it's a safety argument somebody raised
that in committee which was well what if
something's rewired it's like well what
if a single family home is rewired you
need a permit that doesn't apply here
any permitted work still has to be
inspected so this is about routine
inspections of owner-occupied units only
so I would ask that you would please
there's a member yield the questions
remember it does not yield
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
RSA 155 a colon 7 Roman numeral 3 allows
municipalities to inspect rental units
or inspect units to ensure that they
comply with local building codes the
rationale for this is obvious it's
Public Safety one of the major concerns
that municipalities have is multi-family
units and that's due to the density as
well as the turnover that can occur and
it has resolved many communities have
instituted regular inspection programs
this bill seeks to carve out an
exception in as was mentioned a four
unit of the last unit in which the owner
occupied unit could not be inspected
this of course presents a problem
because it's a quarter of the building
at the very least and it hinders the
ability of the building code inspector
to assess the overall safety of the
building as a result uh it it puts the
safety of both the tenant and the owner
at risk this is why the majority of the
committee recommended that this bill be
voted in expedient to legislate and I
would hope that the house follows the
recommendation of the committee and
pushes the green button thank you
the motion before is the majority
committed report of any speed to
legislature and Hospital 477 Senator
Senator natasto has requested a roll
call at a sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call vote members take
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of inexpity to
legislate in house bill 477. this is a
roll call vote chair recognizes
representative Berry for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
safety arguments can be made about any
building anywhere and Mr Speaker if I
know that a man's home is his castle and
Mr Speaker if I know that four buildings
with four units or less are treated more
like res single-family homes what I now
vote red to stand up for personal
property rights and to keep the
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that bad things can
happen in four units or less
and if I know that those free market
cash real estate offers that were
referenced in a previous bill could
happen at any moment turning any
owner-occupied unit into a rental
instantly
and if I know that even if I live in one
of the units I'd really want to know
that everything was okay and safe would
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of any Suite to
legislator and House Bill 477 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposal
press the red button voting stations are
call Members president had an
opportunity to vote
179 voting yay 191 voting a the motion
fails
what reason does the member rise Mr
Speaker I move ought to pass
the motion before us now is ought to
pass on House Bill 477 a division has
been requested
the motion before us is ought to pass on
household 477 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed or press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
194 148 179 voting a minority committee
majority of the committee on Municipal
and County government to which it was
referred House Bill 485 an act
establishing Deputy Animal Control
Officers
have been considered the same report the
resolve that is inexpeding to legislate
representative Joshua from the majority
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report their
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass from a senate major pootie the
minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
the motion is in order the motion before
us is to the table House Bill 4 485.
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 485 this is a division vote chair
recognizer extended Bixby for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that animal neglect
and cruelty cases can be very
challenging for local police forces
and if I know that the county sheriff's
departments could potentially provide
knowledgeable assistance but if I know
that the method presented in hb485 is
not workable would I vote green on the
tabling motion to allow a better Bill to
be filed next year thank you
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 485 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you'll press a red button
boarding stations are open for 30
seconds
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
293 voting a 73 voting May the tabling
committee on science technology and nagd
which was referred House Bill 92
requiring the adoption of innovative
vehicle emission standards and tune to
section 177 of the federal Clean Air Act
this came to us without recommendation
Senator McWilliams moves ought to pass
and offers Amendment zero seven four
seven h
in your seat pockets
chair the chair recognizes
representative
Thomas
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker this amendment
actually changes the basic build into a
study commission which we don't need
we we've heard this before in our
committee a few years back it's it's the
same thing but this amendment focuses on
three things for us for a study
commission one is the set of the effects
of California
emissions section 177 of the Clean Air
react we know what that what that
section does we don't have to study that
we know for instance that it's going to
ban the member will suspend it is
getting an extremely loud in here the
member has a right to be heard if you
need to have a conversation take it out
into the any room
remember it may continue
thank you Mr Speaker we we know what
this uh section 177 does for instance it
it bans combustion engines uh after the
year 235 but uh that's one of the
requirements of this amendment is is to
study that so and I'll tell you why we
don't need to study that because
we already know what's going on we've
had multiple studies going on on EVS
charging stations infrastructure just to
give you an example there's a bill right
now hb11 that's the establishing a
committee to study electrical your
vehicle charging infrastructure SB 52
just cleared committee this year to
study
um uh to adopt the to create a study
committee looking at EV charging
infrastructure deployment uh a few years
ago we had sp57s 517 which is we're
studying EV charging in infrastructure
we have the New Hampshire Transportation
Council was established in 2018
encouraging new technology for for
transportation and investment
opportunities for things such as EVS we
have the New Hampshire Department of
Transportation that has the electric
vehicle infrastructure investment plan
for August 2022 covers EV charging and
infrastructure we we have the NH
Department of Environmental Services
that oversees the Volkswagen mitigation
trust again for EV charging stations and
infrastructures and finally if you go to
the federal website alternate fuels data
center electricity laws and incentives
in New Hampshire
also has a wealth of information for
charging station infrastructure and how
it could be applied we don't need a
commission another one to study this
again and just as the antidote another
requirement on this on this amendment
would require us to study
what do you call it you got the
automobile
um
supply chain issue well I don't know
what the state can do about the
automobile supply chain issue uh I spoke
to the New Hampshire Automobile
Association they said that's a national
problem we all know it's a national
problem to study that for the state to
me would not be
worth anything so I could go on but
basically we don't need this amendment
uh it's it's for one thing it's not
ready it's it's redundant
we have a lot of studies out there
already to provide the same information
please we don't need this amendment
press the red button to put this
amendment down thank you
chair recognize your represent
McWilliams
speaker
I would encourage you all to take a look
in your pockets in front of your seats
for floor amendment to HP 92. this is a
really short Amendment because it's a
commission a study commission and this
is a really important Amendment because
it was requested by the automotive
Dealers Association which is a
non-partisan group that is looking to
figure out how is New Hampshire going to
address our transition to hydrogen and
electric vehicles because it's coming
um and so that's really the intent of
this amendment is to create a commission
and look at that and figure out what the
best strategy is for our state and what
is the right thing to do for us and for
our businesses and so therefore I would
ask you to vote green and yes support
the amendment so that we can study this
and come up with a plan thank you
and Mr Speaker I request a division
a division has been requested members
who yelled for a roll call said Simon
asked for a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
foreign
four seven H in your seat pockets
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes
representative Thomas for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the New Hampshire Automobile
Association did not request this
amendment but merely said that they
wouldn't oppose it and if I further know
that there are multiple studies out
there already studying EV infrastructure
and charging stations and everything
else and and this amendment kind of
assumes what's going to happen in the
future but we really don't know so with
all these studies out there Mr Speaker
if I believe all of this then would I
not press the red button and put this
amendment down thank you Mr Speaker gee
I recognize representative Munds for
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
internal combustion engines
account for approximately one half of
the emissions of air pollutants that
cause the formation of ground Zone ozone
and one-third of the state's greenhouse
gas emissions causing significant
environmental and health related issues
and if I know that the free market has
already spoken and every major
automobile manufacturer in the world has
announced that it is transitioning from
the production of internal combustion to
zero or low or zero emission vehicles
within the next seven to twenty years
and if I know that New Hampshire is
lagging behind other states in preparing
for this transaction this transaction
transition sorry
and if I know that absent a plan to do
so individual Granite Staters and
businesses in New Hampshire will be
significantly disadvantaged would I now
press the green button to vote in favor
of this amendment to create a commission
to study the adoption of innovative
vehicle emission standards and electric
vehicles thank you the motion before us
is on the amendment zero seven four
seven h
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
your opposal press the red button voting
call Members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
1771 voting yay 194 voting Navy
Amendment fails we're back to Auto pass
Mr Speaker for what reason does a member
rise I'd like to make a motion to table
I don't think a division
tabling motion is in order members will
uh somebody I believe yelled for a
division
oh I'm sorry this will be a division
vote
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 7 92.
this is going to be a division vote
chair recognizes representative adjutant
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that tabling would allow for a
consideration of a topic like this in
the future date and if I know that all
of New Hampshire's neighbors already
have these standards adopted and it
probably would be good to at least
figure out
how the vast majority of the automobile
markets surrounding the state of New
Hampshire and which often comes over our
border interacts with these standards
and Ours
and if I know that we could consider
that in the future would I now support
the tabling motion on hb92
do you recognize Webster and Sweeney for
a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that tabling would
allow consideration of this topic at a
future date would I now vote no so that
another motion may be adopted thank you
the motion before us is the table house
bill 92.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button of
your opposed you'll press a red button
foreign
[Music]
members president had an opportunity to
vote
175 voting a 195 voting a tabling motion
fails
we're back now to ought to pass on House
Bill 92.
the chair recognizes representative
Thomas
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if you
thought this amendment was bad
if this bill passes it puts New
Hampshire on track to adopt the
California emission standards for EVS
section 177 of the clear Act of the
Clean Air Act it puts us in line with
California New Jersey Massachusetts
New York
and and several other states of those
and this bill would forever tie us to
any amendments that would come out of
that bill forever because it's like
taking a poison pill
I don't think New Hampshire wants that
there's a reason why people have been
moving to New Hampshire from those
States I don't think they want us to
become like them
it also creates this uh and if we adopt
this it creates Hefty fines for
manufacturers if they don't meet
emission standards and it also creates a
fine if the manufacturers do not meet
their quotas for getting EVS in into the
state I don't think we want that either
it also prohibits like you heard before
it prohibits any new sales of
combustion-powered vehicles starting in
2035.
well they're just
fellow legislators this is a direct
attack on the free market and freedom of
choice
because after all
I have nothing against Eva cars if you
want to buy one they're good
they're they're good for what people
want to buy them for as long as they
know if you want one it should be your
choice but the government should not be
mandating what you buy
so
you know that is the basic reason why
this bill is bad
we want to be able to have people have
their choice pre-market is at risk here
good government mandates are not the way
of New Hampshire
so please vote red
on ought to pass on this Bill thank you
Mr Speaker chair recognizes
speaker
Bill 92
as originally
drafted
Incorporated pieces of the California
Air Board standard carb
and New Hampshire is not California and
so after much debate and discussion we
determined that it made sense to have an
amendment unfortunately this floor has
already spoken an opinion on the
amendment and so I would ask that you
agree and vote itl on the underlying
the motion before us is
ought to pass on House Bill 92 represent
osana natasto
has asked for a roll call vote it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
the motion before us is
ought to pass on House Bill 92. this is
a roll call vote chair recognizes
representative votes for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that our esteemed colleague from
Concord just suggested that itl is the
proper motion for this bill would I
press the red button on the OTP motion
so that can we can move to the itl
motion thank you Mr Speaker
waving off
the motion before us is on a pass on
House Bill 92 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you approach or press
the red button voting stations are open
foreign
members president had an opportunity to
vote the house will attendance state of
40 voting a 331 voting a the motion
fails representative Vos moves in
expedient to legislate are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
[Applause]
the house will be in order
we are at seven bills left if everybody
will stay in their seats we can get
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred House Bill
161 relative to customer generators of
electricity as group hosts under net
media comes without recommendation
representative Reynolds moves ought to
pass
chair recognizes representative presents
for
fresniff
thank you Mr Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker simply put group host net
metering is when a large customer
generator produces electricity for the
benefit of its group members and uses
net metering as the accounting mechanism
this bill expands net metering by
allowing a customer to net meter their
own excess production and then to also
participate in group host net metering
so what is wrong with expanding net
metering
a report commissioned by the Public
Utilities Commission and published last
October found that net metering does
cause cost shifting whereby regular
electric customers end up subsidizing
the practice of net metering by a small
number of other customers
for that reason this legislature has
been very careful and deliberate in
expanding net metering over the years
furthermore two bills we passed last
year HP 1599 and SB 261 require the
Public Utilities Commission to take up
the issue of cost Shifting the puc has
if we know that cost shifting is
occurring if the puc published a study
showing that cost shifting is occurring
and if last year we passed two bills
directing the puc to address this issue
then it makes sense to allow the puc to
do what we've asked them to do before
making further changes to net metering I
urge you to vote red against the OTP
emotion thank you Mr Speaker I recognize
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
and good evening esteemed colleagues
I'm Ned Reynolds I represent Wards two
three and four of Portsmouth
I'm making my first floor speech I'm
very excited in the uh coveted after 5
dealing with an st e Bill get ready no
um
I promise you I'm not going to use any
acronyms and I'm not going to subject
you to an explanation of the mechanics
of net metering
rather I'm going to describe for you a
scenario that I hope will persuade you
that you should vote
ought to pass
on this bill and remove the outdated
restriction
on group net metering that this bill
addresses
so imagine that five years ago say in
your town
your town decided to try solar energy
and you installed solar on one building
in town say your town hall
uh like most solar arrays on buildings
that uh
array probably provides only a fraction
of the energy that that building
um
you know it's probably only a quarter or
even a third maybe if you're lucky of
the total low to that building but the
solar worked well enough that uh and it
showed Financial savings and it
persuaded a majority of the town that
they should embrace solar fully and do
more
but
very likely
many of the other buildings that you
have in town might not even be suitable
for solar at all and even the ones that
are probably similar situation if you
put solar on them they would the array
would not cover come close to covering
the
total energy load of that building
so the solution to that problem is to
build one large solar array somewhere in
town say on 10 acres behind your Public
Works building
and distribute the bill credits that are
produced by that single array to cover
the load of all the buildings in town
thereby saving your taxpayers money on
under current law the town hall the one
that
already has solar on it
would have to be excluded from that
group net metering Arrangement because
it already has a little bit of solar on
it
so
that would deprive
the town of some savings that could be
covered if that original building or
maybe you had two buildings that were
done originally already have solar now
you build a big solar array to cover the
whole load of the town but because of
this outdated restriction you have to
exclude those buildings that have
existing solar from the group net
metering Arrangement the reason that
exclusion was put in place was because
originally
10 years ago or more the utilities
accounting and billing systems didn't
have the capability to track the the
credits from
a building that had solar plus allow it
to participate in group net metering but
that is no longer the case so this
exclusion is simply unnecessary
and it deprives a town of all the
potential savings that it could achieve
from a group net metering Arrangement so
therefore I urge you to vote ought to
pass
on HB 161 thank you
the motion before us is auto pass and
house bill 161.
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
take your seats this will be a division
vote
uh
the ocean before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 161 this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative votes
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the state's largest utility
paid 20 million 428 thousand dollars for
net metering costs in 2022.
and that expanding net metering will
increase those costs
and if I also know that nothing stands
in the way of anyone buying and
installing as much solar power as they
choose
finally if I know the department of
energy opposes this bill because there
is an open docket at the puc on net
metering costs
would I now press the red button to wait
for a new price tag on net metering
before we swipe our card to buy some
more thank you Mr Speaker chair
representative representative Christian
if I know that there is no compelling
technology logical or financial reason
to prevent individuals with renewable
generation in their home from purchasing
supplemental energy as needed from
whatever provider they choose
and if I know that this bill provides a
simple fix for an inadvertent
unnecessary and inappropriate limitation
on local control and individual consumer
choice
and finally if I know that with natural
gas at prices as high as they are we
should be doing everything that we can
to support our customers or constituents
and saving money with renewable energy
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 161 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button the Bony stations are
foreign
this
is bigger
role members president had an
okay
now have all members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
172 voting a 187 voting a the motion a
lot of pass fails okay I recognize the
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
Speaker I move in expedient to legislate
the motion before us is inexpity into
legislate on House Bill 161. are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
Jose
the eyes have it
majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred House Bill 251 and act relative
to the cost of compliance with the
disclosure of electric renewable
portfolio standards considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with Amendment so
Doug Thomas for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
falling resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislators and have rent
Ned Reynolds for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is zero five four eight H
Clinton and house record 14 page 36. are
you ready for the question on the
a division has been requested
the motion before us is the committee
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you will press the green button of
your approach we'll press the red button
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
182 148 166-49 the amendment is adopted
now we have the majority report of Auto
passes amended on House Bill 251 the
thank you Mr Speaker
once again
not going to lecture you with a
technical explanation of anything
just going to remind you that on this
bill
as we all know the
utility system is the farthest thing
from a free market that could possibly
be
it's incredibly complicated
this uh bill is about
the
renewable portfolio standard which
you've heard a lot about and
the reason that you should vote
against
ought to pass
for this bill
it purports to inform consumers but it
would inform them in a very one-sided
way
it would inform them of the total amount
of the very small charge that all of us
pay on our electric bill
each month to support the renewable
portfolio standard
that our state has
and that every other New England state
has
and that collectively result in
a significant depression of Demand on
the Electric System
which translates to significant cost
Savings in the Wholesale Electric market
which benefits all consumers
but that's a a difficult calculation and
a difficult explanation
to disclose to Consumers
so this bill
would
put a number on the electric bill at the
end of the year and and supposedly
inform consumers of the cost that they
are paying for the renewable portfolio
standard without
informing them at the same time
of the benefits of the renewable
you should vote
do you recognize representative Doug
Thomas
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker there's
nothing complicated about wanting
someone to know what your charges are on
your electric bill and this and and that
was determined several years ago by the
general court when they said that the
RPS would at the end of the year would
have uh information on there that told
you how much the on the average uh a
person spent on RPS the only problem was
they did it in terms of kilowatt cents
per kilowatt hours this bill all this
bill does is it says take that average
and apply a dollar amount for the
previous year so for instance if we if
this was in effect last year we would
know that in 2022 that
the average person spent about 39 on
their electric bill for the RPS program
if they average 625 kilowatt hours
by putting that information on the bill
it gives more visibility more
transparency to your electric bill so
someone can say oh gee I averaged about
twice that much last year so I probably
spent about I'll say 78 dollars just it
makes it easier for them to see a dollar
amount versus point zero zero zero six
four cents per kilowatt hour that's all
this bill does it does it at no cost to
the taxpayer all the utilities agreed to
it doe agrees to it and I think please
press the green button to pass this bill
so we can have transparency and make it
easier for people to know what they're
spending on on their electric bill thank
you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the
majority report of Auto pass has amended
on House Bill 251. are you ready for the
question
although
division has been requested members take
representative Sweeney has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of ought to pass that
Amendment on House Bill 251. this is a
roll call vote care recognizes
representative Corman for a
thank you Mr speaker
and as a math guy I kind of wish I could
be doing this Pi on March 14th
of compliance with the renewable
portfolio standard that would appear on
each customer's bill is just that an
estimate based on the average
electricity usage over all customers
and if I know that for any individual
customer this estimate could bear no
relation to that customer's actual usage
which would make it misleading
and if I know that the bill sent to each
customer would contain information about
only the cost of compliance with the
renewable portfolio standard and nothing
about the benefits that the renewable
portfolio standard confers upon all
customers
and this is the last one if I know that
including only one-sided information
introduces bias into the electric
utility bills that every customer in New
Hampshire would receive then Mr Speaker
would I press the red button and vote no
care recognized representative votes for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the buyer of any product wants
to know the cost of what they are buying
and if I know that this bill simply
places on their December electric bill
the average cost in dollars and cents
to comply with the renewable portfolio
standard
and finally if I know that transparency
for government mandated programs should
be of Paramount importance to every New
Hampshire citizen would I press the
green button to shine a light on our
renewable energy expenditures thank you
Mr Speaker the motion before us and
majority committee report of ought to
pass that Amendment on House Bill 251 is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press a green button if your
opposer press a red button voting
adjective
well members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
186 voting yay
committee on science technology and Nat
to which was referred House Bill 281
relative to lease cost integrated
resource plan of utilities this comes to
us without recommendation Senator
Bernardi moves ought to pass
chair recognizes representative Wendy
Thomas
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues oh yeah I'll take this off
colleagues I come before you to impose
the OTP motion for house bill 281.
one of the challenges of presenting
energy bills is that sometimes the
topics are dry and complex and it is up
to us to break them down so that they
can be understood it is also up to us to
keep you from falling asleep
I shall try to do my best on this doozy
of a bill
every two years the utilities must file
for puc review and approval of something
called leased cost integrated resource
plan
the review must occur by way of an
adjudicative proceeding which means that
the Advocates and anyone who has
interest in the proceeding can
participate
this policy also acts as a review of
resource development decisions before
they occur as a way to control
exorbitant utility investment
all utility spending decisions from
wires down the street to deployment of
advanced meters to the construction of a
huge pipeline must be looked at with
regard to the big picture
so the least cost integrated integrated
resource plan explains the big picture
and the utilities must prove that the
plan is managed in a manner that saves
customers money
they must do this while still advancing
the official quote New Hampshire energy
plan
okay so what's that
as set forth in RSA 378 37 it is to
quote meet the energy needs of the
citizens and businesses of the state at
the lowest reasonable cost while
providing for the reliability and
diversity of energy sources
to maximize the cost of of efficiency
energy or to effective Energy Efficiency
and other demand I'm sorry and other
demand sides resources and to protect
the safety and health of the citizens
and the future supplies of resources
with consideration of the financial
stability of the state's utilities now
that's quite a mouthful
but it's a reasonable moderate and
successful policy that protects all
this is not just homework that the
utilities have to do by Statute they are
required to submit a detailed leased
cost plan that looks at the big picture
and that proves that their proposal is
both cost effective and a good idea
the utilities must also look at
protections for our environment
and yes sometimes this may theoretically
mean that even whales need to be
considered
because the utilities are required by
law to look at the big picture in
totality
they must also look at protections for
the health of citizens and they must
provide assurance that the lease cost
plan is used to maximize Energy
Efficiency all again at the least cost
it sounds like a win-win to rate payers
for me
why would anyone throw away these very
important considerations and protections
is the process a little outdated yes the
integrated planning statute was adopted
in 1990 it could definitely stand to be
updated but not nuked
you might have read in the calendar that
quote the principal reason for the
statute no longer exists thus these
plans are no longer being submitted and
reviewed
this statement is quite frankly false
least cost plans are still in are still
being submitted to the puc and they are
still being reviewed eversource recently
had a hearing with the puc on their
leased cost plan they have to it is
required by current law
but this bill proposes to eliminate the
entire process and replace it with
nothing not a zilch Zippo not a debt a
darn thing
we consumers and rate payers would lose
all protections we wouldn't even be able
to participate in the process there
would be no guarantees that the
utilities would truly pursue a least
cost option for their projects and you
know who who any higher rates would be
passed on to right yep say hello to the
rate player Ray payers
the very important purpose of these
least cost integrative resource plans is
as an oversight to make sure the
utilities are doing their job safely and
effectively without wasting our money it
is as simple as that
when I was young my mother would use the
Expression throwing the baby out with
the bath water
as a child I was horrified at the
thought that anyone would ever do that
as I got older I realized that the
expression actually means don't discard
The Good by throwing all of something
away
I am still horrified that anyone would
ever do that and I am horrified that
that's what this bill intends to do
by getting rid of the least cost
integrated resource plan this proposed
Bill throws out a very important baby
that is responsible for oversight and
customer protections and guarantees with
the utilities
let us all save this precious baby and
vote no to OTP in order that another
more reasonable motion can be made
thank you and Mr Speaker I'd like to
a rogue we're down to our final speaker
a roll call has been requested
and it is officially seconded so members
take your seats
the chair recognized representative
Bernardi
thank you Mr Speaker
HB 281 repeals RSA
378 37 through 40.
it concerns the policies plans and
compliances compliance for filing lease
cost integrated resource plans which are
filed by the utilities with the puc at a
minimum of every two years
now some may consider it a cure for
insomnia
but that wasn't the purpose or isn't the
purpose primary purpose of the bill or
of the law the primary purpose is to
have utilities justify placement of
their new production facilities
why why do they need to do that
because utilities made money
and more money by citing decisions than
virtually any other major production
decision they made
but then something happened
divestment
utilities no longer own their production
facilities
so the primary reason for
now are there some dogs and cats issues
in there that still could be attended to
yes there are
but then something else happened
the department of energy
RSA
12 P colon 7 and 7A created a division
of policy and programs that creates a
10-year energy strategy that's updated
every three years
and it deals with these dogs and cats
issues and the puc deals with them when
they entertain the rates the utilities
have to uh set when they bring the when
they bring the cases in front of them
so
creates a division of policy and and
programs but the policy plan deals with
protection reliability and modernization
of infrastructure
including connectivity of new production
and even Renewables
so the bottom line is this particular
part of our law is outdated and not
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 281 this is a roll call vote
does the member yield the questions
yes
thank you Mr speaker thank you for
taking along my question
as you know I'm a former puc
commissioner and with the exception of
one person in the room the prime sponsor
of this bill I believe I'm the only
person who's ever reviewed a lease cost
integrated resource plan and having said
that would you believe me when I say
these plans are no longer serve any
useful purpose whatsoever I asked him if
he would believe me when I said they
served no useful purpose whatsoever
yes I believe you they serve no useful
purpose we have other mechanisms to deal
with these issues
OTP this bill
the motion before us is
ought to pass on House Bill 281 this is
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 281 the Civil call vote the
chair recognized representative partial
Mr Speaker if I know that reasonable
ratepayer costs are reliant on the twin
pillars of rate cases and least cost
integrative resource planning and
without the latter there will be even
less resistance against unreasonable
utility rate increases
and further
if I know that least cost integrated
resource planning is one of the very few
statutes that actually require the
Public Utilities Commission to consider
environmental impacts when making energy
decisions
confine Lake
final from testimony
before the committee that many energy
professionals will across the industry
believe that these cost integrated
resource planning should be renewed
refined but definitely not eliminated
what I now press
the red button to oppose OTP so that
another motion may be brought forward
thank you
chair recognize representative votes for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that
requiring utilities to file plans about
the hardware they plan to buy to
generate electricity is no longer
necessary because they no longer make
electricity
and if I also know that the job of the
Public Utilities Commission is to make
sure that utility Investments and polls
Transformers wires and other Hardware
are always prudent just and reasonable
and finally if I know that modernizing
the grid involves vastly more than
resource planning what I now press the
green button to mothball this unneeded
public policy thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 281 it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your poster press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
184 voting yay 168 voting a in a motion
the committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred House Bill
298 relative to placement of personal
wireless service facilities it comes to
us without recommendation
for what reason does it member rise
Mr Speaker I moved to table house bill
298.
the motion before us is the table house
are you ready for the question all those
a division has been requested
the motion before us is the table house
bill 298.
this is going to be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
Mr Speaker if I know that house bill 298
had no communities from the state of New
Hampshire testifying in support of it Mr
Speaker if I know that house bill 298
flies a Powell of federal regulations
and current state regulations Mr Speaker
if I know that 298 is written would
currently hamstring
the finality of the last recommendation
of the 911 Commission which is firstnet
which protects all of your First
Responders and finally Mr Speaker if I
know we should not
rope radio rope
an industry that is trying desperately
to
bring ubiquitous service to underserved
in unserved communities throughout the
state
so Mr Speaker if I know all of those
things what I currently support the
tabling motion on House Bill 298 by
pushing the green button
chair recognize represent a partial for
speaker
if I know that this is enabling
legislation at its most basic level it
provides recommended language that
municipalities May
use and drafting zoning ordinances
around 5G Tower placement
in order to protect historical and
agriculturally significant sites
this language was required
to fulfill the requirement of New
Hampshire RSA chapter 12 K8 and creating
a model ordinance and guideline
further
if I also know
the municipalities may be well advised
to include such language in their zoning
laws even though this bill does not
mandate any such action would I now
press the red button so that this bill
may be heard in its entirety thank you
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 298 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your opposed will press the
red button voting stations are open for
ball members president an opportunity to
309 voting yay 41 vote in a the tabling
the committee on science has knowledge
Unity to which was referred House Bill
372 establishing a commission to study
the short and long-term impacts of
pending National Regional carbon pricing
mechanisms on the New Hampshire citizens
businesses institution and environment
representative Kaplan moves ought to
pass
I rise in opposition to House Bill 372
which calls for a commission to study
carbon pricing we already have over 150
active studies or commissions and we pay
legislature legislators mileage for
attending the meetings the purpose of a
study or commission is to recommend
legislation
and in this case it would be a carbon
tax
we should be trying to reduce our
constituents financial burden and not
add to it with a carbon tax so please
thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise to support HB 372 a bill
that proposes a commission to study the
effects of carbon system carbon pricing
systems on our state
let me just say from the outset that
this bill is not intended to change the
tax structure of New Hampshire nor is it
intended to send a message that we as a
legislature support carbon taxes
either of those two intentions would be
foolish I'm sure you would agree
but let's face the facts
the world is changing rapidly whether we
like it or not
and the likelihood of carbon pricing
systems coming into Force in our country
has never been more clear despite
Passage
of the groundbreaking legislation last
year by the Biden Administration the
build back better Act
than the inflation reduction act
intended to jump start a clean energy
economy and move us away from our
dependence on fossil fuels whose
combustion has already
altered the global temperature and
threatens to continue to destabilize the
climate in historically unprecedented
ways
why do I say that despite the passage of
the Biden administration's ambitious
subsidies and tax credits the case has
never been better for a federal carbon
price in our country after all the
government is spending millions of
dollars on the project of
decarbonization 400 billion in the next
decade to be more precise
that level of spending will reduce our
carbon emissions by 40 percent by 2030
according to the experts the problem is
that that level of spending only goes so
far in meeting our goal of 50 reductions
by 2030 and Net Zero carbon by 2050.
and it's the last 10 percent of
greenhouse gas reductions that is the
heaviest lift so to speak in Industries
like cement and steel and Aviation
so that is why groups like the
conservative committee for a responsible
federal budget are proposing a forty
dollar per ton carbon price that would
slash emissions an additional 10
percentage points beyond the Biden
program
putting us in line with our commitments
to reduce carbon dioxide and other
greenhouse gases to ensure
the stability of the climate for the
next generation of Americans
altering the tax structure by including
a carbon price does not necessarily mean
greater revenues for a government or
greater burdens for individuals or
businesses
if paired with cuts and other taxes or
and means-tested rebates
if done in this way a revenue neutral
way a carbon price is simply a way of
leveling the playing field among energy
generating sources to bring the costs of
fossil fuel combustion the hidden
subsidy that we paid the fossil fuel
industry for burning their product
onto the book so to speak instead of
hiding it under the rug and imposing
those costs on our Public Health
and the welfare and livelihood of our
children
the benefit of carbon pricing also from
a Libertarian point of view
is that instead of the government
picking and choosing winners by dangling
money
in front of individuals and households
the tax system is a Level Playing Field
that everybody plays on
and if your concern is out of control
federal spending
then basing our carbon dioxide reduction
policy
on an economy-wide carbon price also has
clear advantages over the next big green
New Deal
package of spending that we would need
to meet our goals
other countries have already reached
that conclusion
undoubtedly the biggest driver of our
own move to carbon pricing will be the
fact
that major trading partners such as the
European Union Canada and China
have moved to economy-wide carbon
pricing systems on their own and started
to enact tariffs
on Goods coming into their country from
countries such as ours that have no
carbon pricing system in place
the pressure to match with those trading
partners will continue to grow in coming
years
and that is why leaders from companies
such as Conoco Phillips Exelon Exxon
Mobil Ford Motor Company General Motors
Hannon Armstrong IBM and others are
calling for a carbon price and rebate
system that would be preferable for them
instead of
further subsidies and government
spending on decarbonizing our economy
so by studying the likely impacts of
carbon pricing and recommending measures
to place our businesses and people ahead
of the Curve
we would be carrying out our duty as
Leaders instead of
insisting that reality match our
ideological Vision despite all the signs
showing the exact opposite
that's leadership it's what our
constituents want and it's what they
deserve
so please vote Yes
ought to pass on HB 372 to ensure New
Hampshire is on The Cutting Edge instead
of the lagging edge of the changes that
may be coming that will affect every
corner of our economy thank you Mr
Speaker the motion I call for our
division
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 372 a division has been
the senator Paul has requested a roll
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 372. this is going to be a
roll call vote chair recognizes
representative votes for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that 60 of Americans oppose a
carbon tax
and if I also know that at its core a
carbon tax is a transportation tax
and that every good
purchased by an American citizen is
transported from its maker to the buyer
thus driving inflation higher and higher
finally if I know
that it's not productive to study a tax
that's very unlikely to become reality
in the foreseeable future
what I press the red button
to prevent further waste of valuable
resources on a
on something of dubious quality
thank you Mr Speaker
I recognize representative creation for
Mr Speaker
know that the international landscape
for carbon pricing has changed
substantially since the last time the
legislature considered this issue
if I know that many countries including
our neighbor just to the north currently
participate in carbon markets and have
instituted or are exploring border
adjustments for carbon
if I know that these changes are going
to impact New Hampshire rate payers and
businesses in the future whether we pay
attention to them or understand them or
not
and finally if I understand that this
bill is to study the potential impacts
of other bodies decisions on New
Hampshire interests not to recommend or
even study the possibility of state
level legislation
and finally if I agree with the great
Winston Churchill that failing to plan
is planning to fail would I now press
the green button
the motion before us is ought to pass
and house bill 372. this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposed or press a
red button voting stations are open for
services
fall members president had an
opportunity to vote I also attend the
163 voting a 188 voting a
[Music]
representative daughter moves in
expedient to legislate are you ready for
the question
all those in favor say aye
[Applause]
[Music]
the eyes have it in inexpedient to
majority of the committee on state and
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
house hcr5 enact urging The Taking of
appropriate legal action against
multinational fossil fuel companies for
harms incurred from disinformation
campaigns about the effects of fossil
fuel combustion having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate instead of Tom Manion for
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation of Bill ought to pass
Senator Christine Siebert for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker
honorable colleagues my name is Candace
O'Neill and I represent Hampton
Rockingham 29.
I'm here today to speak in strong
support of hcr5
urging The Taking of legal action
against major fossil fuel companies
more than four decades ago the major
fossil fuel producers knew what the rest
of us now know as certainty and with
widespread scientific consensus we are
facing an urgent climate crisis the
likes of which modern humans have never
before encountered
scientists employed by those very
companies projected today's temperature
rises with stunning accuracy instead of
working with Congress to mitigate damage
and identify solutions they embarked on
a massive cover-up disinformation and
fraudulent marketing campaign
as a result we lost 40 Years of
opportunity to course correct and must
now adopt expensive and burdensome
policy changes in order to avoid the
worst potential outcome to this crisis
even with those actions we our state our
towns our businesses ourselves our kids
our grandkids we will face Decades of
Damages losses and costs directly
attributable to the burning of fossil
fuels
after learning of the looming danger
fossil fuel companies adopted three main
approaches first deny the existence of
climate change second if it exists point
the blame elsewhere and third shift the
burden of combating climate change to
the individual rather than to the big
corporations to say that climate change
doesn't exist or to acknowledge that it
exists but deny the direct link between
the burning of fossil fuels and global
warming is to say that somehow we in
this room know more than the brightest
Minds at Nasa the ipcc the U.S Global
change research program and locally at
the University of New Hampshire
with regard to their final tactic I'm a
child of the 80s we were taught that it
was our generation's responsibility to
fix the environmental crisis before us I
remember being in the third grade
joining a North club and holding bake
sales to buy an acre of land in the
rainforest to this day I feel guilty if
I'm brushing my teeth and I forget to
turn the water off or if I show up at
the grocery store and forget my reusable
bags the member will suspend
it is getting awful noisy in here we're
down to our last two bills the member
has a right to be heard I'm almost done
I promise
individual efforts are wonderful but
what
the fuel companies knew is that these
changes on the micro level would never
be enough to combat the single biggest
contributor to global warming the
burning of fossil fuels it's eerily
reminiscent to Big tobacco glamorizing
cigarette smoking in their marketing or
Purdue farmer Pharma pointing the blame
for opiate addiction at patient abuse of
this medication the cold reality and the
facts before us clearly show these
companies knew four decades ago that
global warming would occur they knew
that it was directly linked to fossil
fuel consumption and they knew that the
only way to mitigate the damage would be
policy change on a national and Global
level
all of us in this room came here to
represent the people of New Hampshire
we live in a state that will be directly
and severely impacted by climate change
it is time for New Hampshire to join
with other states before us to be an
example to the rest of the nation and to
step up and speak out in honor of the
generations that will follow ours who
will face the worst consequences of
global warming and to hold these
companies accountable in the only manner
they will respond to I urge you all to
support hcr5 and vote no on itl thank
you
thank you Mr Speaker
I encourage members to read the
committee's well-written majority report
the calendar by our representative from
Pelham
this proposed resolution refers to
quote
catastrophic risk denial and
disinformation
cherry-picked testimony
fake experts and conspiracy theories
really
is Ronald Reagan might say let's take a
little walk down memory lane
in terms of disinformation and
conspiracy
a generation ago we were warned of ice
ages Global famine rising sea levels
melting ice caps overpopulation and
polar bear Extinction none of which came
to pass
countless
so house will be in order
I'll try to be short
countless so-called experts
told us a generation ago
that we were about to run out of oil
in the 80s the 80s folks like ucal
ecology Professor Kenneth Ward many
others predicted that we'd run out of
crude
by the year 2000.
in 1989 NASA climate scientist James
Hansen predicted
that by 2009 Manhattan would be
underwater
in 2009 Al Gore
predicted that the arctic ice cap would
completely melt by 2015.
and finally in 2019 climate expert and
activist representative
Alexandria
ocasio-cortez declared without
that without immediate and drastic
climate action quote
the world is going to end in 12 years
unquote we could go on and on
the truth of the matter is that we did
not run out of oil in 2000 and in fact
by 2020
America had become amazingly energy
self-sufficient in the net energy
exporter
that is a fact that is not
disinformation but sadly dubious
Washington energy policies have changed
out the last couple years damaging our
economy and threatening our national
security
I just returned from the West Coast
where six dollar a six dollar or a
gallon gasoline is uh is the norm five
to six dollars that hurts the poor that
hurts the poor more than anyone
so most of all
and most of us including the energy
companies favor a reasonable and
tempered transition away from fossil
fuels as opposed to a radical break
indeed these reviled energy companies
are at the Forefront
if you don't know this you should these
energy companies have been at the
Forefront
of energy research and developing
Alternatives and Renewables this is the
energy companies that we're reviling
that we want to shake down
so windmills and the like do have their
place and the Energy Mix but there are
other green sources here in New
Hampshire Seabrook station has provided
an amazing amount of green energy since
1990 with zero zero carbon emissions and
yet ironically climate radicals have
done everything they could to hinder or
shut down
seabrook's operation going back to the
70s
also at this moment there are hundreds
and hundreds of commercial aircraft I
just got off one crisscrossing our
country
they need jet fuel they can't fly on
batteries so there's a place for
Resolutions in this body
the HR 7 resolution supporting Social
Security came out of our state federal
committee
with unanimous support and it passed
overwhelmingly at the last session here
but on the other hand this particular
resolution
hcr5 looks to be
not
it was not unanimous out of committee
it looks to be overly partisan and
contentious
so the hope is that colleagues will
support the committee's itl
recommendation thank you Mr Speaker
[Music]
the motion before us the majority
committed report of inexped into legit
on hcr5
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently second that it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of inexpensional
legislative and hdr5 this is going to be
a roll call Road
chair recognized representative Seibert
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that fossil fuel
companies produced and promoted
disinformation with the intent to delay
addressing climate pollution and its
long-term effects
and if I know that money talks and other
states are currently working to hold
these companies accountable as well
through legal action then would I vote
against the committee report of itl
thank you
I recognize representative Moffat for
thanks again Mr Speaker if I know that
climatology is not a precise science
with data subject to a wide range of
interpretation and projections and if I
know that a vibrant energy companies are
not only crucial to our nation's future
well-being but they are already
investing heavily in Renewables and
energy Alternatives and finally Mr
Speaker if I know that most all of us
here today got here with the help of
fossil fuels would I then go green and
press the green green button to support
the committee's itl resolution uh
recommendation thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of index Community
legislator and hcr5 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposal press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
[Music]
oh
members president an opportunity to vote
189 voting yay 158 14 a committee report
this is the bills removed from the
ah hold on
this is the last one I'm getting
confused
committee on Minnesota County government
which was referred House Bill 294 an act
enabling municipalities to adopt a child
tax credit having considered the same
report the same with the Fallen
resolution that is inexpedient to
legislate representative Tim Cahill for
now the chair recognizes representative
Davis thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to
make a motion
the motion is in order the motion before
us is the late House Bill 294 on the
table are you ready for the question all
the eyes have it and 294 is laid on the
table
the chair recognizes
the member from Auburn representative
Osborne for the third reading motion
resolve that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session be in order at the
present time that the reading of bills
be by title only and resolutions by
caption only and that all bills ordered
the third reading be read a third time
by this resolution and that all titles
of bills be the same as adopted and that
they be passed at the present time and
when the house adjourns today it be to
meet Thursday March 16th
2023 at 9 00 A.M
members please stay in your seats so we
can finish our business of the day
the question is on the third reading
motion are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
announcements
thank you Mr Speaker the Edna committee
is meeting tomorrow Friday at 1 45 to
act exec house bills 457 and 559. thank
you
chair recognize your representative
Weiler
fellow free and accepted masons you know
who you are next Thursday we'll be
having a supper after this session and a
meeting and a a meeting of the Masons
thank you
chair recognizes the clerk thank you Mr
Speaker just a couple of quick
announcements for you please uh per the
request of the sergeant-at-arms staff
you are requested to please wear your
security pin or a name tag when we are
in session we have had some folks
wandering in places they're not supposed
to be not members but other folks so we
are asking on behalf of the
sergeant-at-arms team to please wear a
name tag or your security pin thank you
a couple other things a reminder water
only in the chamber and that means no
snacks despite how tasty Cheez-Its are
um votes being excused if you are going
to leave please check out with me by
text stopping in or sign out in the
speaker's office and your votes will be
excused if you leave at two o'clock and
don't tell anybody we're not excusing
your votes you've been warned lastly the
best time of year is coming up the house
clerk will be hosting the nonpartisan
rules Roundtable lunch next Tuesday at
noon in the cafeteria at uh on Tuesday
the 14th so if you are a nerd and like
rules and parliamentary procedure come
we have a couple of unanimous consents
we're asking the members to stay in your
seats we still have business to complete
good evening colleagues
I just wanted to remind you of a little
bit of History our constitution
on part one article 12. reads every
every member of the community has a
right to be protected by it and and in
enjoyment of his life liberty and
property
he is therefore bound to contribute his
share in the expense of such protection
and to yield his personal service where
when necessary if you'll remember that
they had militias in those days that
were state controlled on because of that
we also have in part two article 5.
full power and authority is hereby given
and granted to the said General Court
I'm emitting a whole bunch of stuff
about education for instance on to
impose and Levy proportional and recent
reasonable assessments rates and taxes
upon all the inhabitants of in Residence
within the said State and upon all the
states within the same to be issued and
disposed of by warrant in the necessary
defense and support of the government of
this state and the protection and
preservation of the subjects thereof so
I would like to not hear anything more
about taxation is theft thank you
the house the house will be in order
chair recognizes representative
Stu Mr Speaker the clerk and the rest of
my esteem colleagues for attempting to
cross the Wall earlier I promise I will
not make the Freshman mistake again and
thank you to my friend from Salem for
very quickly pointing me in the right
direction that's all
[Applause]
thank you
chair recognize representative Sweeney
thank you Mr speaker thank you to
everyone I know we want to get home so I
will be quick we all do know that we do
live in chaotic times politically uh we
live in a and we're serving in a
historic session of the legislature we
have experienced just within the last
few weeks sometimes your team has a good
day sometimes your team has a bad day
and that's just the way it's going to go
but we do not see the same level of
chaos that we've seen in other states in
this legislature and I just want to
commend my friends from across the aisle
on the other leadership team for their
help in their work to make sure that
while we may
one side may be in the majority one day
and the other the other we are making
sure that is as smooth as possible all
credit to the speaker as well for making
it happen we're showing New Hampshire
and the rest of the country in the world
how it's done doing it the 603 way and
we should all be proud of that so thank
you
[Applause]
representative
Motion in place the previous remarks in
the permitted Journal without objection
representative Rockland moves at the
house stand in recess or the purpose of
introduction of bills and Road Bill
amendments and Road build reports and
receiving messages are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
say the eyes have it the motion is
adopted the house is in recess until